schafft warnt vor gravierenden folgen
des klimawandels
3pc fordert entschlossenes handeln
ich würde gerne die aussprache eröffnen
und bitte alle auf der regierungsbank
jetzt auch sich entweder zu setzen oder
den saal zu verlassen natürlich genauso
bei allen abgeordneten
dann eröffne ich die aussprache und das
wort erhält lisa barum für bündnis 90
die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren wir wollen
unabhängig werden unabhängig von
russischen energien aber auch insgesamt
unabhängig von schmutzigen energien
soweit also der bundesfinanzminister
christian lindner hier in seiner
pressekonferenz um 14 uhr hier im
bundestag hat die aktuelle stunde
angefangen nach der veröffentlichung des
berichtes des weltklimarats epc und da
wollen wir gleich rein hören wenn die
erste rednerin ist schon am rednerpult
lisa bardong ab frau im ausschuss für
klimaschutz und energie für die
abhängig
solidarisch sein heißt dass wir jetzt
auch unsererseits an der seite von polen
und bulgarien stehen denen putin heute
den gashahn abgedreht hat diese drohung
stand schon länger im raum und daher
haben beide länder ihre gasspeicher gut
gefüllt aber lassen sie uns das nicht
auf die leichte schulter nehmen zum
beispiel bulgarien war zu 90 prozent von
russischem erdgas abhängig und wir
wissen nicht was gazprom als nächstes
einfällt was sie als nächstes tun wollen
um zahlungen rubel durch zu pressen
dieses anliegen scheint ihm ja sehr
wichtig zu sein es gibt keine absolute
sicherheit unsere energieversorgung ist
in jeder hinsicht ein risiko auch für
uns und für unseren planeten und pirat
ist warum das dass es kein ngo bericht
sondern es haben weltweit
wissenschaftlern wissenschaftler mitte
geraten und regierungsvertreter aus
allen staaten der erde haben diesen
bericht bestätigt sie wissen von diesem
bericht erst relevant für uns alle ich
möchte mit der guten nachricht
einsteigen auch die gibt es weltweit
sind die kosten für erneuerbare für
sonne und wind in letzten zehn jahren um
85 prozent gesunken das ist gut aber
umgekehrt ist umso fataler und umso
unverständlicher dass wir weiterhin in
der fusion welt feststecken dass unsere
investitionen in fossile energien die in
erneuerbare energien übersteigen und das
spiegelbild dieses feststecken diese
abhängigkeit das sind unsere co2
emissionen die rasen nach oben es gibt
keine atempause und wenn wir unsere
fonds ihren infrastrukturen jetzt so
verwirklichen den wald wie sie geplant
sind dann überschreiten wir uns 15 grad
ja die grenze die wir uns eigentlich
setzen wollten und wir können natürlich
auch dass sie den leuten und sagen drei
oder vier grad welt was bedeutet das
schon so schlimm wird es schon nicht
kommen aber meine damen und herren
konsequenter selbstbetrug der reicht
tiefer als die russlandpolitik der
letzten jahre ist auch in diesem fall
eine gefahr für uns bei zwei grad mehr
erhitzen sind bis zu drei milliarden
menschen auf der welt bedroht von
chronischem wassermangel bei 4 katar
dazu ist jede zweite art weltweit vom
aussterben bedroht ich könnte noch
weitermachen
dürrekatastrophen aber ich möchte es ein
zusammenfassen mit dem satz von amina
mohammed vizechefin der vereinten
nationen die menschheit befindet sich in
einer spirale der selbstzerstörung
dieses szenario beinhaltet noch mehr
kriege noch mehr
menschenrechtsverletzungen noch mehr
vertreibungen das ist letztlich das
maximale sicherheitsrisiko und diese
spirale können wir nur gemeinsam
aufhalten wir müssen jetzt unsere co2
emissionen senken
das muss das pik sein was wir erreicht
haben und deswegen verabschieden wir in
diesen wochen die größte ausbauoffensive
erneuerbare energien seit bestehen des
eeg das wird zentral seien für das
erreichen unserer klimaziele
aber ich will auch klar sagen es geht um
den ausbau erneuerbarer energien das ist
der wichtige baustein aber es geht auch
um effizienz und um energie sparen denn
am grünsten ist jede kilowattstunde die
wir nicht verbrauchen
und ja kann nicht nur wir können nicht
mehr meine damen und herren die
technologie ändern die wir benutzen wir
müssen unser verhalten ändern unsere
verfahren ändern wenn wir wirklich eine
klimaneutrale wirtschaft wollen deswegen
ist es richtig dass wir im entlastungs
paket auch höhere effizienz standards
beim bauen verabschiedet haben und wir
sollten wir müssen noch weiter gehen wir
brauchen auch vorgaben für die
wirtschaft dass sie diesen törn schafft
dass sie wirklich wettbewerbsfähig ist
und bleibt
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren die
lage muss ernst sein wenn sogar der adac
seine mitglieder zum spritsparen aufruft
wenn sogar in dieser stunde die csu
landtagsfraktion über die 10h windkraft
abstandsregelung berät aber es kann
nicht bei appellen und bei beratungen
bleiben wir müssen ins handeln kommen
und im übrigen position regelungen
abgeschafft werden gina lisa
bloom war das für bündnis 90 die grünen
im deutschen bundestag hat sie diese
aktuelle stunde eröffnet die auf
verlangen der ampel
koalitionsfraktionen die wir
stattfindet nächster redner ist andreas
jung für die unionsfraktion und kollegen
wenn wir heute hier über klimaschutz
debattieren dann denke ich auch an
unseren langjährigen kollegen josef
göppel der heute vor zwei jahren heute
vor zwei wochen viel zu früh verstorben
ist als kämpfer für die bewahrung der
schöpfung hatte sich in diesem haus weit
über fraktionsgrenzen hinweg großen
respekt
das würdigen sie mit ihrem applaus und
wir beginnen mit einem zitat aus seiner
letzten rede die er im juni 2017 hier im
bundestag gehalten hat er sagte dort als
förster habe ich in meinem leben durch
beobachtung eines gelernt immer dann
wenn man sich mit einer maßnahme den
kreisläufen der natur nähert dann liegt
man richtig denn das was sich in der
natur über jahrmillionen herausgebildet
hat zum beispiel der rhythmus der natur
können wir mit erneuerbaren energien
aufgreifen ich denke dabei besonders an
die stabilität die in der bewegung der
natur lebt an die stabilität die in der
bewegung der natur liegt wenn wir uns
diesen neuen easy bericht vor augen
führen dann müssen wir feststellen diese
stabilität ist nicht nur bedroht sie ist
heute schon betroffen sie ist heute
schon verletzt die folgen der klimakrise
sind schon heute verheerend sie werden
noch verheerender sein wenn die
erwärmung über 1,5 grad
hinaus ginge und noch verheerender als
vor jahren von den wissenschaftler des
pc und weltweit angenommen und deshalb
ist die eindrückliche und eindeutige
botschaft auch dieses berichts neuerlich
in besonderer deutlichkeit dieses
berichts die zeit zu handeln ist jetzt
und das sage ich auch deshalb so
ausdrücklich sagt auch deshalb so
ausdrücklich weil wir natürlich jetzt
betroffen sind und in besonderer weise
damit befasst sind eine gemeinsame
internationale antwort zu geben auf
putins krieg in solidarität mit der
ukraine in zusammenarbeit der
internationalen gemeinschaft und das
muss sein dass er mit vielem zu tun es
hat auch mit energie zu tun und bei der
frage wie wir kurzfristig bekommen von
russischen importen bei der
energie in deutschland in europa da wird
es sicherlich auch umwege gehen müssen
aber wir müssen es von vornherein mit
diesem handeln verzahnen auf allen
ebenen deshalb ist gerade die
internationale gemeinschaft gefragt
diesen prozess des pariser abkommens
weiterzuführen der schwieriger wird wenn
mindestens ein land in dieser weise aus
der internationalen gemeinschaft
ausschert wenn darüber hinaus
schwierigkeiten drohen aber es muss
weitergehen das ist ein prozess
souveräner staaten der schwierig ist es
geht immer nur mit gemeinsamen
vereinbarungen und um ihn anzutreiben
brauchen wir jetzt
eine allianz von vorreitern die sich
gemeinsam standards setzen die gemeinsam
weiter gehen die gemeinsam
partnerschaften auf den weg bringen die
technologie austauschen bei energie
zusammenarbeiten
etwa in industrieregionen und
windreichen regionen wo nicht die frage
im vordergrund steht wie kann man
abhängigkeiten aufbauen sondern wir
partnerschaften auf augenhöhe zu dem
nutzen auf allen seiten zum gemeinsam
voranbringen nachhaltige entwicklung
gemacht werden und in diesem kontext
sehe ich die wasserstoff strategie der
bundesregierung die auf den weg gebracht
wurde in den letzten jahren die jetzt
fortgeführt werden muss konsequent dazu
gehört dazu gehört der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien der beschleunigt
werden muss der in aller breite
vorangebracht werden und ist natürlich
bei sonne und wind aber auch mit den
potenzialen der geothermie mit der
nutzung der biomasse und ihre potenziale
jetzt in dieser krise schnell
dazu beizutragen gas ersetzen mit mehr
möglichkeit mit mehr potenzial und es
darf den erneuerbaren energien nicht das
wasser abgegraben werden auch die
wasserkraft wird weiter einen wichtigen
beitrag leisten das ist unser maßstab
bei den beratungen das von dem was jetzt
ansteht und das muss ergänzt werden
durch die wasserstoff strategie mit den
partnerschaft mit infrastruktur die lng
terminals die jetzt beschleunigt
vorangebracht werden die müssen die
blaupause sein überhaupt für
beschleunigte verfahren es muss alles
schneller werden wir hatten es gerade
von den verkehrswegen es geht um
stromtrassen um die infrastruktur
generell um den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien es muss beschleunigt
vorangebracht werden die zeit zum
handeln ist jetzt international im
kontext der europäischen union unter uns
in deutschland herzlichen dank im
[Applaus]
jüngsten bericht schreibt der apps ist
sie dass der handlungsdruck deutlich
gewachsen es muss rasche und drastische
senkung des treibhausgas-ausstoßes geben
nina scheer jetzt für die spd-fraktion
die situation des klimawandels ist
dramatisch
damit die temperatur nicht um mehr als
1,5 grad beschreiben zwei grad gegenüber
dem vorindustriellen niveau steigt
müssen die globalen co2 emissionen
spätestens in drei jahren sinken für 15
grad muss die treibhausgas menge schon
2030 um 43 prozent gegenüber 2009 10
zurückgehen nachdem pc erhöht jedes
weniger an maßnahmen das risiko die
wende für jahrzehnte zum stagnieren zu
bringen es ist also ein wettlauf mit der
zeit
insofern ist das für den klimaschutz
nach der prämisse von global handeln
denken und global hatten uns privat
global denken und lokal handeln
tschuldigung für uns ein zentrales
vorhaben der kommenden wochen die
hemmnisse zu beseitigen die heute mit
den aktuellen rahmenbedingungen einen
beschleunigten umstieg im weg stehen
genehmigungsverfahren für
windkraftanlagen dürfen nicht jahre
dauern sie dürfen höchsten monaten
nicht darum muss eine
selbstverständlichkeit sein es müssen
deutliche vereinfachungen für kommunen
für landwirte für bürger in der
gesellschaften und für weitere akteure
geschaffen werden das muss einfach
selbstverständlich werden
und sie muss auch in richtung
europäische kommission deutlich
ausgesprochen werden gerade in diesen
zeiten kann es nicht sein dass maßnahmen
zur beschleunigung der energiewende und
damit des klimaschutzes in
beihilferechtlichen
notifizierungsverfahren hängen das kann
nicht sein
europäische bank handlungsbedarf besteht
zudem auch etwa um nur ein beispiel ein
weiteres zu nennen bei der umrüstung des
erdgasnetzes auf wasserstoff wir laufen
zurzeit in parallelstrukturen hinein die
uns letztendlich auch eine soziale
schieflage bescheren können wenn dann
nur noch wenige übrig bleiben bei den
veralteten jetzt auch das ist eine enorm
große herausforderung
verhinderte energiewende und klimaschutz
machten sind immer auch verhinderte
friedens optionen und auch die
energiepreis situation verlangt eben
diesen beschleunigten umstieg auf
erneuerbare energien auch wenn erst
gestern abend erneut eine einigung auf
entlastungsmaßnahmen in der ampel
koalition gelungen ist klar ist und
bleibt wir haben eine preiskrise die
unseren weltweiten abhängigkeiten von
fossilen energieressourcen und nichts
anderem geschuldet sind zudem
beschäftigen uns auswirkungen und die
kommen obendrauf des russischen
angriffskrieges auf die ukraine und
dessen folgewirkungen auf unsere
energieversorgung neben der loslösung
von russischen importen muss auch hier
gelten wir brauchen den
schnellstmöglichen umstieg auf
erneuerbare energien auch im interesse
von energie sicherheit und auch wenn es
im zeitalter der erneuerbaren energien
importe geben sie werden und dürfen
keinen neuen einseitigen import
abhängigkeiten auslösen
erneuerbare energien sind überall
verfügbar und werden durch immer
fortschreitende optimierung der sektor
blinden technischen möglichkeiten auch
immer günstiger und vielfältiger
einsetzbar
von 2010 bis 2019 sind die kosten pro
einheit für solarenergie um 82% gesunden
für windenergie um 55 prozent wir
erleben allerdings zugleich dass die
produktionsstätten seit jahren aus
deutschland abwandern es sind uns über
die letzten jahre schon rund 100000 wenn
nicht sogar 130 tausend arbeitsplätze im
bereich der erneuerbaren energien
verloren gegangen so kann es nicht
weitergehen
hier muss auch der perspektive einer
industrienationen und als energiewende
pionierland dass wir sind dringend eine
kehrtwende eingeläutet werden um
wertschöpfung zu sichern und klimaschutz
aktiv mitgestalten zu können deswegen
arbeiten wir unter hochdruck an einem
bündel von gesetzen dem oster und sommer
paket die umstellung der
energieversorgung ist dabei eine
abschlag eine abschließende wir haben
auch andere bereiche ja das ist klar
aber es ist eine notwendige
voraussetzung um die klimaschutzziele zu
erreichen und auch dem g7 vorsitz
deutschlands kommt dabei natürlich eine
herausragende bedeutung zu und die
möchte kurz noch mal eingehen auch auf
die bedeutung des außenhandels
ausnahme muss in jeder hinsicht teil der
lösung und nicht teil des problems sein
wenn aber energiewende und
klimaschutztechnologien verdrängt werden
da der markt die vermeidung von co2 und
andere nachhaltigkeitsziele nicht
ausreichend anerkennt steht aber eben
auch hier handlungsbedarf wir gehen
damit ein ganz ausgleichsmechanismus an
aber das ist nicht ausreichend wir
müssen weitere maßnahmen ergreifen
rahmenbedingungen zum
grenzüberschreitenden handel müssen
gewährleisten dass energiewende und
klimaschutztechnologien keinen teil
sondern einen vorteil erfahren
klimaschutz und
energiewende im internationalen wie
nationalen kontext sind immer auch eine
gerechtigkeitsfrage
die meisten
armutsrisiken werben indem nicht zu
verhindern nicht verfügbarkeit von
energie bestehen und ich komme zum
schluss unsere solidarität mit der
ukraine sollte bereits jetzt auch mit
umfassen das eine soll das wiederaufbaus
der ukraine der umstieg auf erneuerbare
energien auch im bund für die ukraine
enthalten vielen dank für ihre auch noch
sagt
nina scheer
die spd hat hier auf die umfassenden
hebel hingewiesen mit denen natürlich
auch der klimawandel angegangen werden
kann zum beispiel handelt aber natürlich
auch zum beispiel über energiepolitik
und der energiepolitische sprecher der
afc spricht jetzt kastenwesen meine
damen und herren liebe landsleute zu
weihnachten singen zumindest christliche
kinder das schöne lied alle jahre wieder
kommt das christuskind und mit gleicher
zuverlässigkeit beschert uns dass ein pc
der selbsterklärte weltklimarat einen
weiteren seiner apokalyptischen berichte
noch einen und noch einen und noch einen
diesmal mit dem bericht der
arbeitsgruppe 3 der wohlfeile
anleitungen enthält wie man die bösen
treibhausgasemissionen doch noch
vermindern könnte doch anders als im
berühmten weihnachtslied welches
hoffnung und sägen verspricht kommen die
berichte nicht wird hoffnung und segen
sondern mit düstersten prophezeiungen
über den immer schneller kommenden und
sicheren weltuntergang der uns allen
droht wenn wir diesen vorgaben nicht
sofort und unumkehrbare ohne rücksicht
auf verluste koste es was es wolle
folgen sowie die kirche mittelalter die
menschen mit dem fegefeuer in angst und
schrecken versetzte so sind es heute
weltuntergangspropheten die grünen
kommunisten die die menschen mittels
angst um erziehen wollen könnte man das
wort welt oder ganz steigern würde dass
sie genau das tun da das nicht geht
beschränkt es sich darauf die zukünftige
welt in immer düsteren farben zu malen
und das unverdrossen immer und immer
wieder die grünen kommunisten ihre
mitläufer und die von ihnen gesteuerten
leitmedien gewähren diesem
wissenschaftlich verbrämten unsinn jedes
mal wieder ein riesen podium und
posaunen alles ungeprüft in die welt sie
nutzen die klima ideologie ich sag das
bereits vor drei jahren als ein vehikel
und letztendlich sozialistisch
kommunistische verhältnisse einzuführen
mit all seinen annehmlichkeiten die
sozialismus immer und überall mit sich
brachten vollendung und freiheit um
erziehung zu menschen zur
obrigkeitshörigen sklaven millionen tote
dabei wäre es ein leichtes gerade im
zeitalter des internets die bisherigen
prognosen einer überprüfung zu
unterziehen was ist in den vergangenen
50 jahren ein weltuntergang prophezeit
worden was davon ist eingetreten das
wäre eine leichte übung für jeden
seriösen wissenschaftler wenn er weiter
als seriös gelten will doch macht dass
das mpc machen dass die zu ihm zu
arbeiten wissenschaftler oder die
medienmacht dass die regierung die ihre
extrem teuren und zerstörerischen
maßnahmen damit begründung und eine
verantwortung die ihren steuerzahlern
und der ganzen bevölkerung gegenüber hat
sie machen es nicht weil sich dann
zeigen würde dass nicht eine der
prophezeiungen eingetroffen ist sowie
tausende wissenschaftler die hypothese
der hypothese widersprechen dass die
menschen gemachten co2 emissionen das
klima maßgeblich beeinflussen haben
einige von ihnen speziell beleuchtet
welche horror prognosen der letzten 50
jahre denn wirklich eingetreten sind es
ist wie zu erwarten war keine keine
einzige jeder gab es eine kommen der
tochter bis millionen von hungertoten
wegen zunehmenden ressourcen mangel an
fossilen brennstoffen weder weder doch
statt nun zu sagen wir lagen falsch
passten die weltuntergangspropheten ihre
prophezeiungen einfach an aus seiner
eiszeit wurde die klimawirkung aus
dieser dann die klimakrise weil die
fossilen energieträger partout nicht zur
neige gehen wollten wurden sie zu
schwersten umweltsündern erklärt und
weil nicht sichtbar ist was die wirkung
des verhassten co2 auf das weltklima
belegt weil nicht mal die anderen länder
der welt jene die nicht von dieser
wohlstandsverwahrlosung wie deutschland
und die eu befallen sind den pariser
vorgaben folgen und stattdessen ihre
emissionen munter und ungebremst erhöhen
werden zeuge beweise vorgelegt wie zb
die behauptung des umweltministeriums
orkanstürme überschwemmungen und dürren
oder längere trockenperioden infolge des
klimawandels nehmen zu das ist zwar wenn
man klima zeit maßstäbe anlegen würde
grottenfalsch wird aber gern genutzt um
dem menschen so viel angst zu machen
dass sie freiwillig auf vollkommen ohne
zu techniken umsteigen wie sie das bei
pcc in seinem jüngsten bericht empfiehlt
als da wären wasserstoff e mobilität
energiegewinnung aus riesigen
umweltzerstörenden wind industrieanlagen
und solarfeldern hauptsache teuer
hauptsache ineffizient hauptsache
unbrauchbar aber gut geeignet jede menge
geld zu verbrennen und die regierung
brüstet sich einmal mehr auf dem
richtigen weg zu sein es gibt ein
schönes sprichwort schreibe nichts der
böswilligkeit zu wenn was durch dummheit
hinreichend erklärbar ist das mag ja ein
teil der altparteien abgeordneten zu
treffen die strippenzieher allerdings
die konstrukteure des sogenannten great
race at sind nicht dumm sie gehen sehr
gezielt vor um erstens milliarden an
profiten zu kassieren und zweitens die
menschen in einen zustand zu führen den
herr spart mit folgenden worten
beschrieb sie werden nichts besitzen und
sie werden glücklich damit sein wie es
auf den möchten auch dass menschen
glücklich sind voraussetzung dafür ist
aber im gegensatz zu den grünen
kommunisten aus unserer sicht freiheit
demokratie und wohlstand dafür steht die
fdp und dafür verstehen vielen dank
kersten hilfe war das unter anderem mit
einer kritik an den aktuellen bericht
des pcs ist ein gremium der vereinten
nationen dem fachleute aus der ganzen
welt angehören und 165 länder mitglied
sind olaf in der beek spricht jetzt für
die fdp fraktion
er ist klimapolitischer sprecher
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ein neuer
bericht des weltklimarates liegt vor und
die wissenschaft warnt weiter vor den
gravierenden folgen des klimawandels es
zeigt aber auch den kleinen spielraum
den wir noch haben die müssen wir nun
wirklich nutzen es stehen natürlich
große herausforderungen aber lassen sie
uns diese auch als chance begreifen und
zwar vor allem mit dem was deutschland
statt immer stark gemacht hat die
innovationskraft wo die kreativität
unserer menschen aber
aber der ip system also der weltklimarat
sagt das neueste technologien und
effiziente instrumente verstärkt genutzt
werden sollten wir haben in deutschland
kluge köpfe denen diese umsetzung
gelingen wird der weltklimarat benennt
dabei etwa stehtische negative missionen
oder auch den emissionshandel auch die
wirtschaft hat längst begriffen dass
gehandelt werden muss und ich kann ihnen
sagen diebe kolleginnen und kollegen
viele unternehmen sind schon wesentlich
weiter als das hier im politischen
berlin manchmal
angekommen ist und wir wahrhaben wollen
daher ist unsere aufgabe vor allem diese
schon lange begonnen ökonomische
umstellung bestmöglich durch gute
rahmenbedingungen zu unterstützen
bundesfinanzminister lindner hat bereits
angekündigt bis 20 26 allein 200
milliarden für klimaschutz und
transformation bereit zu stellen das
begrüßen wir ausdrücklich
denn so wollen wir die wirtschaftlichen
veränderung unterstützen der
verantwortungsvolle zielgerichtete und
effiziente einsatz dieser mittel steht
zielgerichtete und effiziente einsatz
der mittel steht versteht sich von
selbst damit wollen wir auch die
rahmenbedingungen schaffen um noch mehr
privates kapital für den klimaschutz zu
mobilisieren
die aktuelle herausforderung
machen den umgang mit dem klimawandel
natürlich nicht einfacher denn nicht nur
der pcc bericht sondern auch das agieren
russlands muss bei der energieversorgung
damit auch beim klimaschutz zu einem
umdenken führen die lösung und der
schlüssel sind und bleiben die ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien
der begriff der begriff freiheits
energien wurde dabei völlig zurecht
verwendet nur der schnelle ausbau dieser
freiheits energien wird uns in zukunft
unabhängiger von energieimporten aller
art machen damit das gelingt haben wir
einiges zu tun denn die umstellung auf
klimaneutralität scheitert häufig nicht
am willen der beteiligten sie scheitert
an der überregulierung in unserem staat
bürokratie und verwaltung dürfen der
klimawandel den kleber der klimawandel
nicht im wege stehen sie müssen helfen
sie müssen auch der beschleuniger sein
die neuesten gesetzesvorhaben zur
beschleunigung des ausbaus erneuerbarer
energien werden wir nicht nur
konstruktiv begleiten sondern die ampel
wird hier auch vorantreiben doch nicht
gesetze alleine sorgen für veränderung
kein windrad wird von alleine aufgebaut
liebe kolleginnen kollegen keine
solaranlage kommt automatisch aufs dach
wenn wir wirklich klimaneutral werden
wollen müssen wir zum beispiel auch
bausteine wie den fachkräftemangel
endlich in den griff bekommen gerade
handwerkerinnen und handwerker sind
unsere klimaschützer vor ort
aber
aber natürlich brauchen wir auch den
rückhalt aller wenn wir erfolgreichen
klimaschutz betreiben wollen die
belastung müsse sich deshalb in grenzen
halten die ampel arbeitet hier auch an
weiteren konkreten durch als zentraler
baustein zur entlastung wird auch das
klima geld sein natürlich müssen wir
auch über die internationale dimension
des klimaschutzes reden unser wirkung
für mehr internationale vereinbarung ist
wichtiger denn je und natürlich kann und
wird deutschland der welt zeigen dass
auch als industrienationen die
transformation hin zur klimaneutralität
möglich ist diese verantwortung haben
wir und dieser verantwortung werden wir
auch gerecht dazu hat sich die ampel
regierung einiges vorgenommen auf
europäischer ebene wollen wir den
emissionshandel auf die sektoren gebäude
und verkehr ausweiten das ist ein
weiterer schritt auf dem weg zu einem
globalen emissionshandel nicht nur dazu
kann ein internationaler klima club ein
wichtiger beitrag leisten abschließend
muss man sagen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen lassen sie uns die
herausforderung annehmen aber gemeinsam
mit den bürgerinnen und bürgern den
unternehmen also der gesamten
gesellschaft dann werden wir die
notwendige zielstrebigkeit haben oder
auch meistern davon bin ich überzeugt
und das ist auch das credo der neuen
bundesregierung vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
olaf in der bild hat hier natürlich auch
den begriff freiheits energien genutzt
geprägt wurde der von seinem parteichef
christian linder obwohl ja gerade die
fdp auch darüber diskutieren möchte ob
akw es eventuell länger laufen sollten
ralph lenkert jetzt für die
linksfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin geehrte
kolleginnen kollegen
wir sind zu langsam
wir sind nicht konsequent
wir übernehmen zu wenig verantwortung
wir suchen gründe wir reden wir zerreden
und das schlimmste behandeln nicht
obwohl wir die letzten generation sind
die den klimawandel eingrenzen können
und müssen
die durchschnittstemperatur in
deutschland erhöht sich derzeit alle
zehn jahre um 0,4 grad das vergangene
jahrzehnt war bereits 1,9 grad wärmer
als das klimatologische mittel
warum reden wir heute in einer aktuellen
stunde erneut über bekannte erkenntnisse
statt konkrete maßnahmen zu
verabschieden
wir sind zu langsam bei der
verkehrswende wir brauchen mehr busse
straßenbahnen mehr züge und mehr
elektrifizierte bahnstrecken damit man
nicht nur in berlin leipzig oder jena
sondern auch in sömmerda bad sulza oder
klein neuhausen endlich ohne eigenes
auto mobil sein kann
zwingen wir volkswagen elektrische
straßenbahn und wasserstoff züge zu
bauen
wir sind nicht konsequent beim umbau
unseres energiesystems
brechen wir die macht der
energiekonzerne
damit strom gas und wärme systeme
zusammenwirken stadt in konkurrenz
ressourcen zu verschwenden
wir brauchen dringend energiespeicher
und wasserstoff elektrolyse
stärken wir kommunale stadtwerke wir
brauchen dezentrale regionale
stromspeicher flexible bioenergie mehr
wind- und solaranlagen geothermie und
auch abwärmenutzung
wir übernehmen keine verantwortung gegen
gefährliche spekulation sinnlose
verschwendung und klimaanpassung die
linke fordert eine
finanztransaktionssteuer das verringert
hochfrequenzhandel spart strom und
ressourcen für hochleistungsrechner der
banken verbieten wir bitcoin
mit konzerten transfer verbrauchten mehr
strom als die gesamte schweiz
verhindern wir immobilienspekulationen
und luxussanierung die vernichten
dringend benötigten wohnraum
wir brauchen die energetische sanierung
mit ausreichender förderung für
warmmiete neutralität damit mieten
bezahlbar sind so
bauen wir unsere stellungen zu
schwanstetten koppeln hochwasserschutz
mit wasserspeicherung gegen dürren
begrünen der stadtquartiere gegen hitze
sommer
wir suchen gründe warum einfache
maßnahmen nicht gehen
verabschieden wir endlich ein tempolimit
verbieten wir kurzstreckenflüge unter
500 kilometern und binden wir industrie
subventionen an auflagen zum klimaschutz
wir reden über kreislaufwirtschaft statt
wo es möglich ist wegwerfprodukte zu
verbieten die linke fordert mindestens
zeiten für produkte und reparatur
garantien zwingen wir die industrie
waschmaschinen zu bauen die zehn jahre
halten
zwingen wir sie zur verfügbarkeit von
ersatzteilen wechselbaren akku zu
verpflichten upgrades auch nach jahren
und kolleginnen und kollegen auch zu
einheitlichen ladegeräten für handys
tablets und laptops
ja und wir zerreden die probleme durch
die energiewende wir brauchen die
akzeptanz der menschen auch für
windkraftanlagen
die linke fordert 15 bis 20.000 euro für
standortkommunen windkraftanlage und ja
wir brauchen endlich bundesweit
einheitliche netzentgelte und industrie
tarife die flexibilität beim
energieverbrauch belohnt und wir
brauchen eine energie preisaufsicht
gegen die spekulation
wir handeln nicht entschlossen wir
müssen den energie und
ressourcenverbrauch senken wegkommen von
permanenten konsum wachstum wir brauchen
mehr weg statt ein weg brauchen
regionale produktionsketten für kurze
transportwege regionale wertschöpfung
und für arbeitsplätze im ländlichen raum
dann sinkt die abhängigkeit von den
puppen und menschen müssen weniger
pendeln
kolleginnen kollegen ostern war ich im
sauerland tode wälder wie im harz
kahlschläge wegen stürmen dürre und
borkenkäfer und in jedem tal auf jedem
berg das gleiche sehen wir im thüringer
schiefergebirge im norddeutschen
flachland
ich habe angst dass wir den waldumbau
nicht rechtzeitig schaffen hat das
starkregen den boden weg spürt und in
kopplung mit hitzewellen eine
wiederaufrüstung misslingt ich habe
sorge dass wir die letzte generation
sind die grüne welle in deutschland
kennt der worte sind genug gewechselt
wir müssen handeln vielen dank
und als nächstes erhält das wort für die
spd-fraktion timon gremmels
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren der
weltklimarat hat seinen bericht vor drei
wochen veröffentlicht wäre es vor drei
monaten gewesen wäre dass die top
schlagzeile in der tagesschau gewesen
vor drei wochen ist es um das tarifen
gelaufen weil der krieg in der ukraine
alles andere überdeckt deswegen ist es
gut dass wir als koalitionsfraktionen
diesem tagesordnungspunkt hier heute auf
die sitzung des deutschen bundestages
gesetzt haben um darüber zu reden weil
natürlich ein krieg in der ukraine nicht
dazu führt dass der klimawandel gestoppt
ist diese themen müssen und werden wir
weiter behandeln müssen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren und der krieg
in der ukraine macht ja noch mal
deutlich dass wir uns viel viel
dringender und deutlicher von russischen
fossilen energien befreien müssen und es
kann auch nicht sein oder es kann nur
geduldet werden für einen übergang dass
wir das ersetzen durch fossile energien
aus anderen ländern das darf nicht dazu
führen dass wir fossile kraftwerke
länger laufen lassen denn ist müssen
aufpassen dass hier kein login defekte
gibt meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren was wir stattdessen tun müssen
ist die erneuerbaren energien deutlich
schneller auszubauen ohne sehr verehrten
damen und herren gröhe generalsekretär
coach hatte anlässlich der
veröffentlichung vor drei wochen gesagt
wir seien auf der überholspur richtung
klima desaster ich befürchte guterres
hat recht lassen sie uns im
übertragenden sinne doch ein tempolimit
für diese co2 belastung auf den weg
bringen für ein solches tempolimit hat
sicherlich auch die fdp verantwortung
und interesse daran wir müssen jetzt
sequent erneuerbare energien ausbauen
und das zeigt ja auch dieser bericht
dass hier sonnenenergie windkraft und
das aufforsten dazu führen kann dass das
die königs wege sind aus dem klima pfad
hin zu erneuerbaren energien jede dieser
option hat das potential zehn prozent
der jährlichen treibhausgas emissionen
zu vermeiden das sind doch konkrete
zukunftsperspektiven die dieser bericht
auch gibt hoffnung perspektiven die wir
jetzt auch umsetzen müssen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren und her wurde
der kollege jungen ich höre ihre rede
hier mit genugtuung und sehe aber auch
die unionspolitiker an anderer stelle
handeln man hätte die cdh regelung in
bayern abschaffen können stattdessen
wird heute ein popanz aufgeführt in
bayern die bayerische cdu landes tags
fraktion beschäftigt sich es bleiben
gesetzentwurf ja wo ist dann
nachbesserungen abschwächungen geben
soll harte diskussion wie ich höre der
csu landtagsfraktionen der welt sie
spricht ja noch nach uns vielleicht
können sie ja gleich hier verkünden dass
den haar fällt das wäre einmalig die
sage ihm wir kriegen dann auch meinen
sie kriegen auch großem applaus von mir
und von dieser seite des hauses also
nutzen sie diese gelegenheit doch
kassieren wie 10h
und auch wenn ich jetzt so cook in
anderen teilen wo die union noch
verantwortung überträgt in nrw auch da
ist es ja nicht so dass hier der ausbau
erneuerbarer energien freie fahrt hat
auch hier gibt es viele stoppschilder
auch hier brauchen wir ein
regierungswechsel damit auch in
nordrhein westfalen ist zum ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien kommt und zwar
nicht nur und zwar nicht für mehr
klimaschutz sondern erneuerbare energien
sind wenn man sie richtig umsetzen auch
immer ein weg um wertschöpfung zu
generieren für kommunen neue
einnahmequellen zu generieren film der
bürger energie projekte richtig machen
können auch bürgerinnen und bürger von
preiswerten erneuerbaren energien
profitieren das ist ein
wirtschaftspolitisches projekt heute
nicht nur ein ökologisches projekt meine
sehr verehrten damen und
deswegen müssen wir gucken gemeinsam
dass wir auch die industrie der
erneuerbaren energien hier in
deutschland halten das gilt für
solarindustrie das gilt für windkraft
industrie für batteriespeicher industrie
für halbleiter industrie das sind
schlüssel
industriezweige für die energiewende für
den klimaschutz hier müssen wir gucken
dass wir das so machen wie bei intel die
bei tesla möglichst schnell hier
schlüsselindustrien anzusiedeln eine
perspektive zu schaffen weil dann schaff
energiewende auch neue gute
arbeitsplätze diesem land meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren
und deswegen ist das was sich diese
ampel koalition vorgenommen hat ein
großes projekt
es ist ein ganz großes projekt was noch
erschwert wird durch den ukraine krieg
aber wir sind dazu verpflichtet dass wir
hier erfolgreich sein werden die
energiewende ist die zukunftstechnologie
und die energiewende ist das was wir auf
den weg bringen dafür werden wir den
nächsten wochen mit oster paket im
sommer paket kämpfen in diesem sinne
alles gute und glückauf
der bundestag diskutiert so lind folgen
des klimawandels und nächster redner ist
thomas cap hat für die unionsfraktion
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren der weltklimarat hat
uns in diesen tagen einmal mehr sehr
deutlich gemacht
sehr deutlich gemacht dass die maßnahmen
die die staaten dieser welt bisher
ergriffen haben eben nicht ausreichen um
den klimawandel zu begrenzen auf ein maß
das als verantwortbar gilt und es ist
völlig klar wir müssen weltweit mehr tun
für den klimaschutz und es ist völlig
klar wir brauchen mehr tempo ist muss
schneller vorangehen als dies bisher der
fall war wenn wir einmal kurz
zurückblicken auf die situation in
deutschland
dann können wir schon feststellen dass
wir in den letzten jahren durchaus auch
einiges erreicht haben das ziel war es
bis 2020 die treibhausgasemissionen um
40 prozent zu reduzieren im vergleich zu
1990 und wir können sagen wir haben
dieses ziel erreicht aber jetzt gilt es
natürlich nach vorne zu blicken jetzt
gilt es konsequent den weg weiterzugehen
hinrichtung treibhausgas neutralität und
das nächste große ziel lautet bis 2030
65 prozent reduktion ein ambitioniertes
ziel übrigens ein ziel das ich bereits
die vorherige bundesregierung gesetzt
hat die ampel regierung hat dieses ziel
übernommen und ich sage wir werden sie
ausdrücklich darin unterstützen in
dieser zielsetzung und dieses ziel zu
erreichen
aber meine damen und herren
ziele sind das eine das andere
und das ist am ende das was zählt was
entscheidend ist das sind die konkreten
maßnahmen um die ziele tatsächlich zu
erreichen und es geht vor allem auch um
die art und weise wie klimaschutz ganz
konkret gemacht wird und wir stehen
dafür dass wir klimaschutz auf eine art
und weise betreiben dass deutschland
auch in den nächsten jahren ein
ökonomisch starkes land bleibt dass ihr
wohlstand generieren dass es sozial
gerecht zugeht und nur wenn uns das
gelingt wenn wir umwelt und wirtschaft
und soziales in einklang bringen nur
dann haben wir eine chance auf
dauerhafte akzeptanz im eigenen land und
nur dann haben wir eine chance dass uns
auch andere länder auf diesem weg folgen
dass wir attraktiv sind in dem was wir
machen beim klimaschutz und der
weltklimarat hat uns dazu wie ich finde
wichtige hinweise gegeben der schlüssel
sind technologische innovation und
deshalb lassen sie uns voran gehen bei
erneuerbaren energien bei
energieeffizienz bei der wasserstoff
strategie aber auch und auch das steht
in diesem bericht sehr deutlich drin
auch bei technologien zur entnahme von
co2 aus der atmosphäre
deutschland sollte an der stelle nicht
nur offen sein sondern wir sollten es
aktiv angehen am besten in form
internationaler kooperation auch das ist
aus meiner sicht ein ganz zentraler
punkt meine damen und herren eine
wichtige eine konkrete maßnahme
um beim klimaschutz hier in deutschland
voran zu kommen ist die förderung von
klimafreundlichem bauen
und wenn wir uns ansehen wie die politik
der ampel regierung in diesen ersten
wochen und monaten aussieht dann muss
man leider an der stelle ein paar
fragezeichen machen im januar gab es
diesen kfw förderstopp dann wurde die
förderung wieder aufgenommen am 20 april
also vor einer woche nach wenigen
stunden gab es erneut einen förderstopp
und das ist nicht nur das krasse
gegenteil von planungssicherheit sondern
es ist ein rückschritt im klimaschutz
meine damen und herren das haben uns
übrigens heute morgen die
sachverständigen im ausschuss sehr klar
gesagt die folge ist dass viele familien
es sich finanziell schlicht und
ergreifend gar nicht leisten können so
klimafreundlich zu planen und zu bauen
wie es möglich wäre und die folge ist
dass mehr emissionen entstehen als
eigentlich notwendig wären und das ist
bitter das ist falsch und deswegen
fordere ich sie an der stelle auch auf
handeln sie und ändern sie an dieser
stelle an diesem punkt ganz konkret ihre
politik herzlichen dank
als nächstes spricht nun stefan seiler
vom südschleswigschen
wählerverband deswegen ist er
fraktionslos
vielen dank frau präsidentin 9 liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen mehr noch als
andere teile unseres landes ist der
norden vom anstieg des meeresspiegels
und den folgen des klimawandels bedroht
und wenn hier weihnachtslieder aus der
ecke zitiert werden frage ich mich
erinnern sie sich auch an aus ihrer
schulzeit an die novelle theodor storms
der schimmelreiter und muss der
nordfriesische deichgraf hauke haien den
bauern eindringlich vor der flut waren
und die notwendigkeit neuer und bessere
deiche anmahnen sie glaubten ihm aber
auch nicht
und auch uns erreichen heute immer neue
warnung durch die wissenschaft dass die
emissionen gesenkt werden müssen und
dass naturkatastrophen uns verstärkt
bedrohen darum will ich auch heute malen
denn es wird zeit und es wird viel zu
wenig fristen schutz getan die westküste
die westküste braucht bessere deiche die
ostküste umfang umfangreichere
entwässerungssysteme für unsere ferne
nur fortwährender schutz vor erosion und
im anstieg des meeresspiegels wert
unseren norden wie wir ihn kennen
erhalten können in denen mag das
aufgrund seiner küstenlage noch stärker
betroffen ist hat die regierung die
investitionen in den küstenschutz
bereits verdoppelt bei uns sind jedoch
die bundesmittel etwa zur ertüchtigung
unserer deiche hinzu klimadaten nicht
ausreichend ich fordere daher die
bundesregierung auf die stärkung der
deiche und sperrwerke als
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe zu
begreifen und die bislang nur 70
prozentige beteiligung des bundes an
küstenschutzmaßnahmen zu erhöhen
auch die mittel für forschungsprojekte
zu umweltverträglichen und effektiveren
küstenschutzmaßnahmen müssen vom bund
stärker unterstützt werden ich fürchte
dass die bis zu 25 millionen pro jahr
aus dem gak sonder rahmenplan 2009 bis
2025 tatsächlich nicht genug sind wenn
wir nicht im vorfeld im vorfeld in
schutz und prävention investieren zahlen
wir später den preis für die zerstörung
durch hochwasser und erosion der zum
schluss der schimmelreiter endet in
einer katastrophe
der alte deich bricht eine
jahrhundertflut begräbt das land und die
menschen stolz erzählungen des kriegs
doch wir heute sind montiert mit der
realität vielen dank
stefan seiler war das fraktionslos
bekommt ihr aber auch
fraktionsübergreifend
applaus für seine rede kathrin
henneberger spricht jetzt bündnis 90 die
grünen sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen während
wir heute diskutieren über die sich
verschärfende dürre und den
ausbleibenden regen in deutschland
leiden die menschen in großen teilen
indiens und bangladesch und pakistan
aktuell an einer extremen hitzewelle mit
bis zu 50 grad eine solche hitzewelle im
frühjahr ist sehr ungewöhnlich
lebensbedrohlich für menschen besonders
für schwangere für kleine kinder und für
alte menschen
verstärkte hitzewelle wie sie jetzt in
indien und pakistan zu treffen werden
schon bald zu neuen grausamen realität
gehören meist betrifft es dabei die
gemeinden die am wenigsten bis gar nicht
zu klima krise beigetragen haben und
deshalb liegt die historische
verantwortung
ernsthaft zu handeln immer noch und
immer dringender bei uns es gibt keine
entschuldigung für unterlassene
maßnahmen gegen die klimakrise
in deutschland in deutschland werden wir
mit den auswirkungen der klimakrise auf
unsere ökosysteme als auch auf unser
leben immer heftiger konfrontiert
aktuell haben wir zu wenig niederschlag
leiden große teile deutschland unter
einer dürre
mit besonders harten auswirkungen für
unsere waldökosysteme und für unsere
landwirtschaft im letzten sommer mussten
wir starke niederschläge und eine
jahrhundertflut erleben die dritte in
den letzten 20 jahren wetter extreme
werden immer häufiger und wir sind es
den menschen schuldig sie zu schützen
und sie darauf vorzubereiten sie zu
unterstützen mit finanzen für klima
katastrophenschutz
um die klimakrise
aufzuhalten müssen wir global denken
global handeln und dafür abkommen die
die klimakrise global ausbremsen diese
nicht mehr existieren lassen damit meine
ich natürlich den energiecharta vertrag
ein schutzabkommen für die fossile in
der industrie für fossile investitionen
auch im bericht des letzten un
weltklimarates ssi wurde genau dieser
energie schotter vertrag benannt als ein
hindernis für eine klimagerechte
transformation sowie der kohlekonzern
rwe auf grundlage dieses
energiesparvertrag es beispielsweise die
niederlande für ihren kohleausstieg
verklagt hat deswegen hat ein klima eine
klimaschutz bremser wieder energie
shutter vertrag keine
existenzberechtigung mehr
als zweites müssen wir aber auch ein
sehr kritischen blick auf internationale
finanzierung von zukünftigen fossilen
projekten werfen
aktuell möchte der energiekonzern total
eine neue pipeline baum in uganda über
tansania zum indischen ozean
die east african pipeline kopp genannt
diese würde auch am victoriasee entlang
führen von die millionen von menschen
abhängig sind die förderung und der
transport des erdöls riskiert die
wasserversorgung der region
klima und menschenrechtsaktivistinnen
die dort versuchen gegen das projekt
aktiv zu sein müssen repressionen
fürchten wir sollten ihn aber sehr genau
zuhören
und ihre forderungen sind die top darf
nicht gebaut werden deutschen
europäische banken dürfen den bau der
erdgas-pipeline kein geld zur verfügung
stellen diese koloniale ausbeutung muss
enden
die förderung von öl gas und kohle führt
in vielen regionen dieser welt bereits
massive konflikte genauso wie es die
auswirkung der klimakrise tun die
klimakrise aufzuhalten und unabhängig zu
werden von den fossilen bedeutet die
grundlage für frieden sicherung unserer
zukunft
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen als ich
geboren wurde lag der co2 die lag die
konzentration von co2 noch knapp unter
350 ppm und im vergangenen jahr wurde
die marke von 400 15 ppm überschritten
die ursache der klimakrise ist
zweifellos die nutzung der fossilen
energien und deshalb führt kein weg
daran vorbei gas öl und kohle gehören
der vergangenheit an
maßnahmen
unsere maßnahmen um die klimakrise
aufzuhalten müssen die wirkung haben
dass es allen menschen auf der erde gut
geht dass alle eine gute zukunft haben
werden wir werden in dieser
legislaturperiode in allen sektoren
dafür notbremse ziehen und die
grundlagen für eine klimagerechte
zukunft schaffen egal ob bergrecht oder
verkehrswegeplan alles gehört auf den
klima prüfstand unsere gesetze müssen
reformiert werden aktualisiert für das
zeitalter der klimakrise indem wir jetzt
leben sie
bequem wäre die annahme dass
technologische wunder uns in 15 oder 20
jahren dann davon hätten in die
klimakatastrophe rhein zu rasen
ob die kipp punkte unseres globalen
klimasystems überschritten werden das
entscheidet sich heute die connections
ist es unsere entscheidung wie wir jetzt
haben den welche maßnahmen wir ergreifen
und am ende möchte ich einige
ausgerechnet an die klimagerechtigkeit
bewegung besonders an die menschen und
welchem klima aktivistinnen den anderen
berger kommt jetzt bittet zum schluss
die letzte satz das mache ich danke ich
möchte meinen dank aussprechen an die
klima- umwelt- und
menschenrechtsaktivistin in anderen
regionen der welt die trotz der
drohungen tödlicher repressionen sich
gegen fossile ressourcen werden vielen
dank euch
der bundestag diskutiert hier in dieser
aktuellen stunde und nächster redner ist
lukas kohler der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp fraktion
nicht mehr weiter nicht der geehrte frau
präsidentin meine sehr geehrten damen
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der pc sonderbericht der jetzt gerade
raus kam hat es sehr viel spannende
arbeiten die wissenschaftler die
wissenschaftler den letzten jahren
zusammengetragen haben aufbereitet und
viel von dem was sie da lesen können
zeigt und das haben die reden und
die debattenbeiträge die wir bisher
gehört haben zumindest die allermeisten
auch schon sehr klug sehr
ausdifferenzierten schreibt da bis sie
sondern bericht ist grundlage für eine
ganze reihe von berechnungen unter
anderem gab es in nature gerade einen
artikel von professor mainhausen der
aufgezeigt hat und durchgerechnet hat
auch wir mit dem aktuellen globalen
budgets eigentlich das was wir uns im
pariser abkommen vorgenommen haben
nämlich erstmal das zwei grad ziel zu
erreichen ob wir dies schaffen und er
sagt ja mit dem aktuellen was wir an
einem sogenannten patch ist also an dem
was die staaten
auf das was die staaten sich geeinigt
haben was sie vorbringen bei den cops
dass wir da diese zwei das ist ja
eigentlich schon mal eine gute maßnahme
aber er führt auch sehr genau aus dass
wir das auch einhalten müssen was wir zu
sagen dass wir die ziele die wir uns
geben auch umsetzen müssen und dazu
braucht es jede menge dinge insbesondere
und das ist ein sehr spannender teil des
ipads es braucht es dazu innovative neue
technologien mit denen wir dinge auch
umsetzen können und mit denen wir in
zukunft nicht nur co2 in der produktion
reduzieren sondern muss auch einsprachen
der
bericht macht noch was anderes auf der
spricht darüber wie ist eigentlich das
globalbudget bestellt wie viel globales
budget haben zur verfügung um und das
ist ja unser ziel das 1,5 grad ziel
einzuhalten also nicht nur zwei grad
sondern er hat sich diese
bundesregierung auch gemietet und meiner
meinung nach das auch völlig zu recht
getan wir müssen möglichst das 105 grad
ziel
und das interessante an diesem business
sie berichtet dass wir diese methodik
noch mal neu aufgreift um zu einem
anderen ergebnis als die vorhergehenden
berichtigt da sagt nämlich dass wir
nicht wie im bericht vorher 20 68 also
2068 welt bei treibhausgas neutral sein
müssen sondern er schiebt das auf die
mitte der siebziger jahre jetzt gab es
ein paar pressestimmen der letzten zeit
gesagt mensch super dann haben wir quasi
mehr zeit mehr erreichen ich halte das
für einen ganz gewagten trugschluss ich
glaube nämlich dass wir und das zeigt
jetzt nicht nur die notwendigkeit
schnelle massnahmen zu beschliessen
schnelle maßnahmen auch in der regierung
umzusetzen und deutschland darauf
vorzubereiten dass raab zeigt auch die
ukraine krisen dieser krieg der aktuell
dafür sorgt dass wir alles überdenken
müssen was wir in den letzten
jahrzehnten an versorgung durch gas
durch öl durch kohle gemacht haben
derzeit dass wir jetzt handeln müssen
und dass wir jetzt vor allen dingen
schnell dafür sorgen müssen dass dinge
einfach umgesetzt werden und wir haben
eine ganze reihe von herausforderungen
von dem wir da bestehen das eine ist die
frage der erneuerbaren energie die frage
wie schnell kommen wir da vorwärts wie
schnell schaffen wir es den ausbau zu
verzieren und ja weltweit sind
erneuerbare energien und das zeigen zb
berechnung der beinahe schon jetzt oder
nicht nur bei einer sondern in vielen
denn dann sind sie jetzt schon
konkurrenzfähig sind sogar günstiger als
fossil inc das ist ein gutes signal gute
zeiten in deutschland sehen wir aber
dass vor einigen großes problem daran
gibt dass wir
bürokratie aufgebaut haben dass wir
dafür gesorgt haben dass zu wenig
flächen zur verfügung stehen dass wir
dafür gesorgt haben dass wir eben an den
stellen an denen es möglich ist nicht
schnell genug vor wir haben doch den weg
gemacht als koalition die
bundesregierung diese hürden abzubauen
ich glaube das ist jetzt ganz zentral
ist denn was wir und meine vorredner hat
es so schön ausgedrückt was wir jetzt
tun müssen ist der welt zeigen dass alle
menschen davon profitieren von wachstum
von vorankommen davon dass sie eben neue
billige energiequelle abend das tun wir
nur durch innovative leistung das tun
wir nur dadurch dass wir beweisen dass
wir wirtschaftswachstum und co2 ausstoß
voneinander entkoppelt und dass die
menschen in anderen ländern perspektiven
haben und ich glaube und deswegen bin
ich auch für diesen weiter zu dankbar
ich glaube wenn wir das beweisen können
dass viel geschafft aber es gibt ein
teil da müssen wir glaube ich sehr
intensiv auch nochmal mit der
bevölkerung es gibt einen teil der pcc
wie kein anderer bericht davor stark
macht und das ist die heute der negative
mission wir müssen ccs nutzen wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass wälder weiter
ausgebaut werden dass nachhaltige
holznutzung passiert dass wir böden
ertüchtigen mehr co2 zu binden wir
müssen aber vor allen dingen co2 nicht
nur reduzieren sondern auch speichern
das zeigt der bericht
ich bin sehr froh dass unsere
ministerin im bmbf das aber auch das
wirtschaftsministerium das die ganze
regierung sich auf diesem weg macht ich
freue mich darauf das noch weiter
auszugestalten das wird auf jeden fall
spannend und ich glaube dann sind wir
auf einem sehr guten weg meine damen und
herren vielen dank und ich glaube wir
schaffen was zu sagen
[Applaus]
der nächste redner debatte dr andreas
lenz fraktion cdu csu
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
momentan stattfindenden krisen zeigen ja
dass wir in der energiepolitik in der
klimapolitik immer auch langfristig
denken müssen zuweilen aber auch
kurzfristig und pragmatisch handeln
müssen wir dürfen aber das große ziel
natürlich nie aus den augen verlieren
und die bekämpfung des klimawandels ist
eine menschheitsaufgabe der wir uns
stellen und der wir uns auch stellen
müssen klar ist es gibt viel zu tun
global aber auch national und wir müssen
jetzt natürlich um so entschlossen da
auch in serbien kommen klar ist aber
auch es wurde in den letzten jahren viel
gemacht und um eines auch ganz deutlich
auszusprechen
wir werden jetzt der ampelkoalition
nicht durchgehen lassen dass quasi die
defizite immer in der vergangenheit
gesucht werden und sich sozusagen aus
der verantwortung gestohlen wird weil
das datum bis dato ist es ja so dass die
ampel koalition nur eine ankündigungs
koalition ist
der bericht der bericht zeigt auf dass
die netto treibhausgasemissionen global
die letzten zehn jahre dramatisch
angestiegen sind im gegensatz dazu sind
die emissionen in deutschland übrigens
gesunken trotz wirtschaftswachstum haben
wir in deutschland weniger co2 emittiert
wir haben die letzten jahre kräftig die
kommuniziert wir haben aber nicht die
industrialisiert wir haben die
erneuerbaren energien aus deutschland
heraus global marktfähig gemacht das
sagt ja auch der bericht ich zitiere die
stückkosten emissionsarme technologien
sind seit 20 10 kontinuierlich gesunken
wir haben die klimaschutzziele
2020 erreicht übrigens nicht nur wegen
corona das waren alles ja wir und es
waren nicht die von der ampel wir
brauchen natürlich jetzt trotzdem ein
mehr an einsparungen aber auch an mir an
erneuerbaren energien und dabei werden
wir alle potenziale brauchen auch die
biomasse auch die wasserkraft und auch
und gerade
die geothermie beispielsweise im bereich
der wärme und sie von der amnestie
unterscheiden doch im geplanten ruster
paket im moment in erneuerbare erster
und in den erneuerbare zweiter klasse
sind quasi gut wasserkraft schlecht pv
gut biomasse schlecht und das ist
kontraproduktiv gerade in der jetzigen
krise wir wollen wir wollen alle
erneuerbaren und wir brauchen auch alle
erneuerbaren um das klar zu sagen
der bericht zeigt übrigens auch dass wir
co2 speicherung möglichkeiten das
sogenannte ccs brauchen um die ziele zu
erreichen genauso wie das nutzen von co2
dass cdu und auch dass die entnahme von
co2 ccs notwendig sein wird das sagt bei
der ampel wir haben es gerade gehört die
fdp im koalitionsvertrag steht dazu
nichts dass koalitionsvertrag sagt dazu
leider nichts sie wollen doch durch die
aktuellen stunden nur davon ablenken
dass sie in der ampel überhaupt keinen
gemeinsamen plan beim klimaschutz haben
und wenn man jetzt mal schaut was die
fdp in der letzten legislatur bezüglich
der bezüglich der frage co2
zertifikatehandel gesagt hat dann sieht
und hört man davon ja im moment auch
nichts mehr der bericht
der würde ich betone übrigens auch das
potenzial im gebäudesektor bei der co2
einsparung hier haben sie durch ihr
förder chaos gerade eine verheerende
verunsicherung verursacht einen
scherbenhaufen bei den entsprechenden
bei der wohnungswirtschaft und bei denen
die sich an einem eigenheim errichten
wollen verursacht und das geht auch
entsprechend auf ihr konto und es ist
doch so und es ist doch so dass
energieeffizienz aber auch der
gebäudebereich bei ihnen aus
ideologischen gründen überhaupt keine
rolle spielt und
letztlich brauchen wir
und letztlich brauchen wir auch einen
massiven ausbau der
wasserstoffwirtschaft wasserstoff daten
nicht nur der champagner der
energiewende sein er muss sozusagen das
leitungswasser der energiewende werden
klimaschutz klimaschutz kann nur global
funktionieren wir brauchen wir partner
schaffen das sagt der bericht auch ganz
klar hier geht es ebenfalls unsere
anstrengungen weiter zu führen
internationale zusammenarbeit bleibt ein
ganz entscheidender faktor wir werden
sie an ihren taten haben erreichten
messen und nicht am angekündigten
herzlichen dank und
andreas lenz war das und damit kommen
wir zu romy näser doch für die
spd-fraktion er sitzt im ausschuss für
klimaschutz und energie
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin verehrte
damen und herren alands wenn die ampel
koalition so schlecht wäre wie sie sagen
dass sie nicht ist dann wären sie immer
noch besser als die cdu die die 16 jahre
lang hier verhindert habe dass die
bayern immer noch gut
aber lassen sie mich zu meinen punkten
kommen viele sagen uns wir müssen uns
unsere art zu leben ändern um unsere
erde zu schützen ich sage wir müssen
unsere erde schützen um unsere art zu
leben behalten zu können warum ist das
ein großer unterschied zu dem wir
gehören viele die wenig geld haben diese
leute sind nicht das problem für das
klima den klimawandel befeuern vor allem
leute die viel geld an denjenigen mit
wenig geld zu sagen sie sollen ihr leben
ändern ist zynisch sie werden am
stärksten unter dem klimawandel leiden
am wenigsten dazu beigetragen haben
natürlich in unserem land leben mehr
leute denen es gut geht und das soll
auch so bleiben aber ihn zu sagen sie
sollen ihr leben ändern ist im ergebnis
zu wirkungslos sie wollen dass es ihnen
weiterhin gut geht verständlicherweise
damit jede veränderung ein risiko und zu
wenige leute sind bereit
nein zu gehen und den klimawandel
aufzuhalten
deswegen kann die forderung aus meiner
sicht nur sein lasst uns unsere art zu
leben behalten und verbessern
damit das gelingen kann müssen wir aber
unbedingt unser klima schützen das sagt
uns der bericht des weltklimarats
schützen wir unser klima nicht erwarten
uns in den nächsten jahrzehnten
regelmäßig und oft
naturkatastrophen dann erwarten und
hitzewellen die für ältere menschen
gefährlich sein werden da unser warten
millionen geflüchtete die ihre heimat
verlieren und bei uns schutz suchen
werden nebenbei wird uns das alles
milliarden kosten die uns für andere
wichtige vorhaben fehlen werden das ist
kein film dass es wissenschaft vieles
davon hat auch schon längst begonnen in
einer solchen welt wird es uns unmöglich
sein so zu leben wie heute es ist also
klar wir müssen unsere erde schützen
wenn wir so weiter leben wollen wie
bisher zwei jahre haben wir noch zwei
jahre steht im bericht des weltklimarats
nach 2025 dürfen unsere
treibhausgasemissionen weltweit nicht
mehr steigen und ab dann müssen wir ja
unsere emissionen deutlich reduziert nur
dann bleibt uns der erde zitat
lebenswert will sagen nur dann können
wir uns reha zu leben behalten
selbstverständlich kann man den
klimarats bericht auch so lesen doch wir
müssen unsere art zu nehmen ändern so
geht das überhaupt nicht weiter was
stimmt nun es kommt darauf an was wir
unter unsere art zu leben verstehen
plastikverpackung benzin und
massentierhaltung sind für mich keine
eckpfeiler meiner art zu leben nicht
weil ich diese dinge nicht nutzen würde
sondern weil es einfach nur dinge sind
wichtiger ist doch welche idee dahinter
steckt zu meiner art zu leben gehören
neben anderen komfort freiheits und
genuss das können wir plastikverpackung
benzin und massen die haltung
ermöglichen dies können mehr aber auch
andere dinge ermöglichen möglicherweise
sind andere dinge sogar noch besser und
klimaverträglich ein beispiel benzin ist
knapp und irgendwann aufgebraucht seit
jahren wird es immer teurer
mit elektromotoren werden wir nahe
zukunft viel günstigeren unbegrenzt
mobil sein können und das auch noch
klimaverträglich fazit der staat sollte
uns niemals vorschreiben nach welcher
art zu leben haben jeder soll nach
seiner fasson glücklich werden der staat
sollte uns aber die rahmenbedingungen
geben nach unserer art leben zu können
und wir haben ja schon gesehen im
klimawandel verlieren wir diese
möglichkeit also müssen wir alle den
klimawandel aufhalten was ist zu tun
vieles wir haben es gehört ich will zwei
aspekte besonders hervorheben erstens
wenn wir den klimawandel aufhalten
wollen müssen wir unsere
entscheidungsfreiheit als einzelne
behalten wir dürfen uns den alltag aber
auch nicht schwer machen wenn ich zb
nach klimaverträglichen lebensmitteln
oder klamotten umständlich in speziellen
läden suchen muss mache ich das meistens
nicht so geht es vielen dass es
menschlich unser ziel muss daher seien
in jedem laden in deutschland kriegen
wir ausschließlich kliemann
sozialverträglich hergestellte produkte
dann liegt die last nicht mehr bei uns
sondern beim hersteller und da gehört
die verantwortung hin wer etwas
produziert muss gewährleisten dass er
sorgsam mit unserem planeten und sein
mit menschen umgeht punkt mein zweiter
punkt wir sind viele sind die gefahren
des klimawandels inzwischen bewusst wir
haben ein kleiner werdendes
verständnisproblem es sitzt dort wir
haben aber ein großes umsetzungsproblem
bei den lösungen nicht macht es wütend
wie lange wir brauchen um windkrafträder
und photovoltaik-anlagen aufzustellen
obwohl eine große mehrheit dahinter
steht darum werden wir das in der
ampelkoalition
radikal beschleunigen im wichtigen
schritt zum schluss das mag ich ein
wichtiger schritt sind die gesetze im
ruster paket mehr folgt man kann
verzweifeln wenn man den bericht des
weltklimarats liest wird dürften es aber
nicht wir arbeiten an lösungen haben sie
vielen dank
so weit so roubini savas und sie haben
es gesehen der saal füllt sich auch die
regierungsbank ist gut gefüllt denn
jetzt kommt es hier zu einer ersten
beratung eines
gesetzentwurfs der schon viel thema war
in der debatte
denn es geht um das bundeswehr
sondervermögen 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen will die bundesregierung
für die bundeswehr ausgeben um sie zu
modernisieren 100 milliarden euro das
ist eine zahl mit elf nullen
das ist eine zahl die auch gebraucht
wird wenn denn die zeitenwende wie von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz angekündigt
wird vollbracht wird denn bislang wurde
viel gespart bei der bundeswehr und es
wurde auch immer wieder gesagt dass eben
da geld fehlt das material fehlt
personal um hier
einsatzfähig zu sein
diese 100 milliarden euro die sollen als
sondervermögen
betitelt werden das heißt dass sie nicht
unter die schuldengrenze fallen unter
die schuldenregelung aber die
bundesregierung möchte auch dieses
sondervermögen ins grundgesetz schreiben
lassen und deswegen braucht es dafür
eine zweidrittelmehrheit hier im
deutschen bundestag das bedeutet dass
auch die union für diese abstimmung
gebraucht wird deswegen ist es hier ein
etwas heikles unterfangen denn bisher
hat die union noch nicht ihre zustimmung
signalisiert sondern hat bestimmte
forderungen an dieses sondervermögen
unter anderem geht es darum
da wie diese 100 millionen euro
ausgegeben werden wie sie auch
zurückgezahlt werden
das wird jetzt hier in der debatte
wahrscheinlich auch diskutiert werden
und wie zum beispiel auch dass zwei
prozent ziel der nato eingehalten werden
kann das fordert die union hier im
deutschen bundestag
und als erster spricht auch der
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
zum sondervermögen bundeswehr
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff russlands
auf die ukraine hat unzählige
menschliches leid verursacht
er hat die friedens- und stabilitäts
ordnung in europa und auch die wirkung
des völkerrechts zerstört wir sind in
eine neue phase eingetreten es ist eine
zeitenwende wie der bundeskanzler
neulich an dieser stelle gesagt hat
russland darf diesen krieg nicht
gewinnen die ukraine darf diesen krieg
nicht verlieren und deshalb
alles dafür
unternehmen wir alles dafür um der
ukraine zur seite zu stehen in der
vergangenheit gab es zeiten da wurde die
deutsche geschichte bemüht für nichtstun
jetzt wissen wir aus der deutschen
geschichte ergibt sich eine
verantwortung dafür dass wir handeln in
deutschland und europa
der angriffskrieg russland verändert
auch die internationale ordnung die
globale governance verändert auch die
sicherheitslage der bundesrepublik
deutschland wie wir erkennen müssen
auch die frage der bündnis und
landesverteidigung spielt heute eine
größere rolle als ihr alle wenige jahre
zuvor
geglaubt hätten es geht nicht um eine
militarisierung der deutschen außen- und
sicherheitspolitik aber wir müssen
erkennen dass die bundeswehr nicht in
dem zustand ist indem sie sein muss
angesichts der veränderten risikoprofils
es geht nicht um eine militarisierung
der außenpolitik aber um eines man muss
kämpfen können um nicht kämpfen zu
müssen und deshalb muss die bundeswehr
ertüchtigt werden
die bundesregierung reagiert auf die
zeitenwende in vielerlei hinsicht und
auch mit dem jetzt hier eingebrachten
sondervermögen bundes wären auf die
anforderungen des bundeskanzlers hin
habe ich als fachlich zuständige
minister ein sondervermögen
vorgeschlagen die alternative etwa
steuern zu erhöhen würde nicht nur aus
ordnungspolitischen gründen sondern auch
angesichts der makroökonomischen
situation gefährlich sein
also haben wir uns für den weg eines
sondervermögens entschieden um 15 jahre
vernachlässigung unserer streitkräfte
schnell zu beenden es ist eine
kraftanstrengung ja diese sondervermögen
wird mit krediten finanziert aber in
dieser zeit in dieser lage ist es anders
nicht möglich den realitäten gerecht zu
werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
angst dazu entschieden ihnen
vorzuschlagen im artikel 87a des
grundgesetzes also in der wehrverfassung
dieses grund dieses sondervermögen zu
verankern damit wird auch schon über den
standort in der verfassung deutlich
welchem zweck es dient nämlich der
stärkung der bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit unseres landes
und insbesondere zur stärkung unserer
streitkräfte
das soll aber niemanden zu der fehler
veranlassen dass die bündnis
verteidigungsfähigkeit unseres landes
ausschließlich nur durch eine stärkung
der streitkräfte erfolgen könnte diese
bundesregierung
diese bundesregierung fühlt sich nämlich
dem ansatz
vernetzter sicherheit verbunden so sehr
wie auch mit diesem sondervermögen
insbesondere auch die streitkräfte
stärken wissen wir dass eine große
priorität auch bei diplomatie und
internationaler krisenprävention liegen
muss
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir führen konstruktive gespräche mit
der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion ich bin
dafür dankbar manches öffentliches
störgeräusch hat es gelegentlich gegeben
die tatsächlichen gespräche finden
kollegial und sachorientiert stadt dafür
bin ich dankbar und so kenne ich auch
die kolleginnen und kollegen der
unionsfraktion von vielen anderen
gelegenheiten
eines aber muss ich sagen es handelt
sich hier um eine entscheidung
historischen charakters
möglicherweise wird man dereinst zurück
schaut auf unsere gegenwart
diese richtungsentscheidung im
zusammenhang mit der vom bundeskanzler
angesprochenen zeitenwende und die
einrichtung dieses sondervermögens in
einem historischen zusammenhang mit dem
nato doppelbeschluss nennen und wenn
tatsächlich diese entscheidung an
solchen charakter hat dann mag ich mir
nicht vorstellen dass die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion einer
gemeinsam ein übung nur teilweise
zustimmt und nicht komplett und
geschlossen
und beschließen es wird schließen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen einer bemerkung
wir sprechen jetzt hier heute um die
materielle stärkung der bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit und insbesondere
unserer streitkräfte das allein wird
aber nicht reichen unterziehen wir uns
bitte einer kritischen selbstprüfung ein
früherer bundespräsident sprach in bezug
auf unser verhältnis zu den
streitkräften einmal von freundlichem
desinteresse
möglicherweise ist das noch zur netz
gesagt als aktiver werdender und
reserveoffizier hat mich mehr als einmal
auf dienststellen mit kameradinnen und
kameraden kontakt gehabt wie nach
dienstschluss gefragt haben ob sie in
uniform nach hause fahren sollen oder ob
sie zivilkleidung anlegen sollen weil
sie möglicherweise in der straßenbahn
schief angeschaut oder gar schief
angesprochen werden das zeigt es gibt
gegenüber unseren streitkräften und
jenen die unser land verteidigen in
dienen in uniform gibt es nicht nur eine
materielle vernachlässigung sondern auch
eine ideelle
vernachlässigung und dementsprechend
müsste man nicht nur die bundeswehr mit
geld und ein sondervermögen mit einem
sondervermögen stärken sondern wir
müssen den soldatinnen und soldaten auch
die wertschätzung dieser gesellschaft
entgegen
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
hat hier gesprochen zum sondervermögen
bundeswehr und wir sehen es auch an der
regierungsbank dass das hier ein nicht
ganz üblicher beschluss ist der nach
einer zweiten beratung gefällt werden
soll bis auf zwei minister sind alle
bundesministerinnen und bundesminister
anwesend
präsidentin sehr geehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen
heute genau vor zwei monaten war es als
der bundeskanzler
hier im deutschen bundestag angesichts
des ukraine krieges eine zeitenwende
angekündigt hat ein sondervermögen
angekündigt hat mehr investitionen in
die bundeswehr angekündigt hat und daran
appelliert hat dass wir gemeinsam diesen
auftrag annehmen in dieser schwierigen
situation zusammenzustehen und die im
angriffskrieg russlands den
angriffskrieg putin die stirn zu zeigen
seitdem hat sich die lage in der ukraine
dramatisch verschlechtert
kriegsverbrechen werden begangen
zivilisten gezielt getötet vernichtungs
drohungen ausgesprochen und genau
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir uns
auch in diesen tagen morgen in einer
debatte aber auch heute am rande des
plenums darüber unterhalten ob
deutschland zukünftig noch mehr
unternehmen kann und auch bereit ist im
bereich der waffenlieferungen mehr zu
unternehmen und schwere waffen in die
ukraine zu liefern meine damen und
herren ich hätte mir es nicht vorstellen
können dass es diese generation von
abgeordneten des deutschen bundestages
ist die über so eine schwere frage wie
die lieferung von schweren waffen und
über die frage von krieg und frieden
mitten in europa mit entscheiden muss
aber es ist unser gemeinsamer auftrag
die selbstverteidigung der türken kräne
zurück stärken und deswegen will ich an
der stelle auch sagen wir wollen
gemeinsam mit den ampel fraktionen die
entscheidung mittragen das schwere
waffen an die ukraine geliefert werden
das ist unser gemeinsamer auftrag und
für frieden in europa zu sorgen
ich verstehe übrigens jeden sack auch
das ausdrücklich der dies mit großer
skepsis auch begleitet und ich verstehe
auch jeden der auf die frage will man
schwere waffen liefern er mit nein
antworten würde aber ich sage auch sehr
deutlich in dieser frage ist es
notwendig diese schweren waffen zu
liefern
und deswegen muss unsere gemeinsame
antwort darauf sein ja wir sind als
deutschland bereit mehr zu helfen was
bisher mehr zu tun und die ukraine in
ihrer selbstverteidigung zu stärken
meine damen und herren
ich darf erinnern dass der
bundeskanzlerin seiner rede am 27
februar uns mit seiner zeitenwende
positiv überrascht hat
damit waren eine reihe von erwartungen
auch verbunden die mit
regierungshandeln zu tun haben leider
müssen wir feststellen dass auch heute
finanzminister sie hinter diesen
erwartungen zurückgeblieben sind die
tatsache und der hinweis darauf dass wir
über viele punkte gemeinsam in
verhandlungen stehen die dürfen doch
nicht als argument sehen dass sie bei
dem gesetz das sie hier vorstellen
wesentliche teile der ankündigung des
kanzlers die wir unterstützen nicht
wiederfinden lässt wir brauchen klarheit
wir brauchen klarheit ob sie bereit sind
diese ankündigung auch umzusetzen der
bundeskanzler sie haben vom
sondervermögen bundeswehr gesprochen sie
haben von rüstungsvorhaben gesprochen da
haben sie uns an ihrer seite dann
erwarten wir aber auch dass genau diese
rüstungsvorhaben im grundgesetz die
nötige antwort finden 100 milliarden
sondervermögen 100 milliarden
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr das
heißt doch nichts anderes als 100
milliarden sondern schulden für die
streitkräfte und zwar 100 milliarden für
aufrüstung der streitkräfte und sie
nichts anderes meine damen und herren
bundeskanzler sie haben in ihrer rede
auch davon gesprochen dass wir zukünftig
nun jahr für jahr mehr als zwei prozent
des bruttoinlandsprodukts in unsere
verteidigung investieren werden liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen was ist denn an
diesem satz eigentlich so
missverständlich dass es der
bundesfinanzminister in seinen
haushaltsplanungen schlichtweg nicht
berücksichtigen kann der
bundesfinanzminister
sie haben heute im bundeskabinett einen
sogenannten ergänzungs haushalt
vorgelegt 40 milliarden zusätzliche
schulden auch in diesem haushalt findet
sich kein aufrufs des
verteidigungsministeriums es profitiert
nicht von ihren milliarden die die heute
vorgestellt hat
das zwei prozent ziel findet sich auch
in diesem haushaltsentwurf nicht herr
bundesfinanzminister wenn sie glauben
sie könnten das versprechen des
bundeskanzlers gegenüber der
öffentlichkeit ab sofort das zwei
prozent ziel zu über erfüllen nur
ausschließlich damit einlösen dass sie
100 milliarden neue schulden aufnehmen
und ansonsten den verteidigungshaushalt
inflationsbereinigt reduzieren dann
werden sie uns nicht an ihrer seite
haben
ich sage dass hier auch in richtung der
verteidigungsministerin und der spd
der fraktionsvorsitzende der spd hat
hier vor kurzem in seiner haushaltsrede
davon gesprochen dass man nachfolgenden
generationen nicht vorschreiben will wie
hoch die rüstungsausgaben sein sollen
das wurde öffentlich interpretiert an
eine klare absage an das zwei prozent
ziel ich will sie alle daran erinnern
seitenwände bedeutet keine einmalzahlung
an die bundeswehr sondern ein
dauerauftrag an unsere
verteidigungsfähigkeit
und auch diesen hinweis weil wir in der
tat ich kann das bestätigen den guten
gesprächen darüber sind ob man eine
einigung erzielen kann aber das ergebnis
ob es zu einer einigung kommt ist offen
wir haben die punkte die angesprochen
wurden sind bisher noch nicht gelöst wir
haben weitere gespräche an dieser stelle
vereinbart und zu diesen gesprächen
gehört auch dass wir uns über eine
solide haushaltspolitik unterhalten
schulden machen alleine ist noch keine
solide haushaltspolitik der
bundesfinanzminister sie können mit uns
weiter verhandeln über die frage ob 100
milliarden euro für die bundeswehr für
die streitkräfte aufgenommen werden aber
sie müssen auch mit uns darüber reden
wie wir diese 100 milliarden wieder
tilgen schuldentilgung ist ein
grundprinzip solide haushaltspolitik und
auch daran erinnern wir sie
alexander dobrindt vorsitzende der csu
landesgruppe hatte unter anderem
kritisiert dass noch nicht klar ist oder
nicht vereinbart wurde im haushaltsplan
wie das zwei prozent ziel der nato
umgesetzt werden soll dieses ziel
wurde 2014 schon in wales von den nato
staaten vereinbart auch damals seitdem
wurde es nicht von deutschland erreicht
der russische präsident putin hat mit
seinem überfall auf die ukraine die
friedensordnung in europa zertrümmert
gewissheiten und vereinbarungen auf
denen das freie und friedliche leben von
millionen menschen in europa aufgebaut
waren es zerstört und heute kämpfen 40
millionen ukrainer um ihr leben dieses
land kämpft um die existenz und
gefallene und ermordete zeigen uns was
auf dem spiel steht sollte putin diesen
krieg gewinnen
und niemand weiß was dann das nächste
ziel wer und wer mit menschen an der
ostflanke der nato spricht der kann
spüren welche sorgen da bestehen dass
sie die nächsten wären die überfallen
werden und die dann nicht standhalten
können das dürfen wir nicht zulassen
dazu sind wir aufgefordert sowohl
unseren verbündeten und sachen
alliierten beizustehen aber auch dafür
zu sorgen dass wir hier in deutschland
sicher leben können meine damen und
herren
auf diesen lokalen angriffskrieg hat die
bundesregierung mit großer
entschlossenheit aber eben auch mit
besonnenheit reagiert und das ist das
gebot der stunde
entschlossen aber eben auch besonnen zu
sein damit diese furchtbare situation
die sagt furchtbare krieg nicht
eskaliert das sind wir den bürgerinnen
und bürgern dieses landes schuldig und
wer sich umhört wer sich ernsthaft um
hört der bekommt genau das gesagt bitte
achtet darauf dass dieser krieg ein
dritter weltkrieg wird bitte sorgt dafür
dass es nicht zu einer eskalation kommt
und genauso werden wir auch in zukunft
handeln in der bundesregierung
auf diese veränderte situation haben wir
durch waffenlieferungen in die ukraine
reagiert aber wir müssen auch hier in
deutschland darauf reagieren und zwar
indem wir unsere eigene wehrhaftigkeit
stärken diese zeitenwende die
mittlerweile international ein begriff
ist sie muss mit leben erfüllt werden
sie darf nicht nur ein begriff sein und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass mit
diesem von olaf scholz vom bundeskanzler
angekündigten sondervermögen endlich
unsere bundeswehr so ausgestattet wird
dass sie ihre aufgabe erfüllen kann die
landes- und bündnisverteidigung
auch zu gewährleisten dass es über jahre
hinweg jahre hinweg zusammen gespart
worden sodass inspekteure der bundeswehr
darüber reden dass wir blank sind das
mag zugespitzt seien aber den kern den
kern trifft es und damit muss endlich
schluss sein
diese 100 milliarden jahren dringend
gebraucht und sie werden nicht alleine
gebraucht für aufrüstung herr dobrindt
weil sie dann für andere dinge auch
gebraucht dafür dass ge endlich dafür
sorgen können dass unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten die schutzausrüstung haben
die sie brauchen
gehen sie doch einmal hin zu der truppe
sprechen sie doch mal mit soldatinnen
und soldaten und dann bekommen sie
erzählt was passt was alles fehlt
deswegen es geht nicht um aufrüstung es
geht auch um ausrüstung es geht darum
dass endlich dieses dieses geschehen
kann langfristige projekte gekauft und
angeschafft werden genauso wie munition
und vieles andere mehr ich will ihnen
mal einige beispiele dann braucht man
diese riesige lücke erkennen kann
zwischen dem was auf dem papier steht
der bundeswehr und dem was wir
tatsächlich zur verfügung haben wir
haben zum beispiel auch ein papier
350 schützenpanzer puma
davon sind tatsächlich
150 einsatzbereit
150 10 uhr einsatzbereit weil die
entsprechenden möglichkeiten nicht
gegeben sind um sie beispielsweise in
stand zu setzen wenn das erforderlich
ist beim kampfhubschrauber tiger sitzt
nicht anders aus von 51 maschinen können
gerade mal neun abheben und bei der
munition die wir dringend brauchen um
unsere verantwortung in der nato
nachkommen zu müssen müssen 20
milliarden eingesetzt werden und das ist
erforderlich und das können wir über
dieses sondervermögen
gewährleisten und dann werden wir auch
die zwei prozent der nato quote erfüllen
können sie haben völlig recht da wird
einiges aus dem haushalt erfüllt ich
habe aber auch die möglichkeit dringend
notwendige anschaffungen vorzunehmen
über dieses sondervermögen und das geld
das im haushalt vorgesehen ist dann für
die beispielsweise diese ausrüstung
einzusetzen so wie wir es jetzt auch
ganz aktuell gemacht haben und da will
ich recht herzlich danke sagen an
diejenigen die im haushaltsausschuss und
den verteidigungsausschuss so flexibel
waren obwohl wir ja noch immer in einer
vorläufigen haushaltsführung sind dass
es schnell gelungen ist 2,4 milliarden
euro und die hand zu nehmen um diese
schutzausrüstung endlich möglich zu
machen die berge plan für 20 31 weil man
nicht das geld zur verfügung hatte 20 31
solange sollten die soldatinnen und
soldaten darauf warten endlich diese
schutzausrüstung zu haben jetzt ist es
gelungen auch weil wir diese perspektive
haben schnell zuzugreifen und schnell
dafür zu sorgen dass das gewährleistet
ist meine damen und herren
diese zeitenwende
so geredet jetzt so so so zurecht auch
in diesem großen anspruch diese
zeitenwende hat auch dazu geführt dass
so viel ernsthafter endlich über militär
endlich über verteidigung endlich über
sicherheitsfragen sprechen diese
ernsthaftigkeit genau die brauchen wir
auch wenn es jetzt um das sondervermögen
100 milliarden geht und ich bin ihnen
dankbar dass sie genau diese
ernsthaftigkeit in dieser woche an den
tag legen und dem antrag dem gemeinsamen
antrag der ampel koalition jetzt doch
zustimmen genau die ernsthaftigkeit
brauchen wir genau genau diese
ernsthaftigkeit brauchen wir jetzt auch
bei den beratungen wenn es um das
sondervermögen geht nicht einfach aus
parteitaktischen spielchen zu sagen da
dürfen dann nur fünf oder nur sieben
zustimmen ich weiß doch dass bei ihnen
in den reihen der union fast alle
abgeordneten ohne wenn und aber hinter
der bundeswehr stehen und da zeigen sie
das auch indem sie diese möglichkeit
über das davon so schlimm vielen dank
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht war das und auf sie antworten
direkt wird jetzt peter böhringer der
haushaltspolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin wir beraten heute einen
heiklen gesetzentwurf der zwar in der
materiellen absicht auflösung des sehr
langjährigen investitionsstaus bei der
bundeswehr begrüßenswert ist wir
unterstützen dieses ziel der aber
haushaltsrechtlich und auch
verfassungsrechtlich bedenklich ist
zunächst wir sind grundsätzlich gegen
sondervermögen weil sie die reguläre
transparente entscheidungsfindung des
bundestages über den haushalt
beeinträchtigen und nun gar noch eine
absicherung über eine
grundgesetzänderung residenz los dieses
sondervermögen wird so nicht nur zitat
des finanzministers neben der
schuldenbremse stehen sondern letzten
endes neben dem haushalt die verfassung
wird missbraucht wenn man eine konkrete
budgetzahlen ins grundgesetz schreibt
und so ohne not einen illegitimen
nebenhaushalt begründet so etwas macht
man nicht völlig ungeachtet des ziels
ordentliche ausrüstung der bundeswehr
was die afg seit jahren recht einsam
fordert
ausgerechnet eine linke regierung könne
etwas tun dass wir zuletzt vor 130
jahren gesehen haben unter bismarck
wurde der militär etat für mehrere jahre
festgeschrieben das sogenannte sap
system und ausgerechnet die ampel will
nun in ähnlicher weise die demokratische
kontrolle einschränken ich sage nicht
abschaffen ich sage einschränken die 100
milliarden bundeswehr mittel gehören
regulär ohne einführung eines
sondervermögens im kernhaushalt
eingestellt und es ist doch gar keine
frage die mehrheit für diese investition
wie wir sie seit jahren fordern wäre
hier im haus problemlos gesichert es
gebe dafür auf lange jahre 80 prozent
mehrheit und zustimmung hier im haus sie
bräuchten keine zu grundgesetz änderung
lassen sie uns also ehrlich sein diese
konstruktion dient ausschließlich der
umgehung der schuldenbremse das
sondervermögen bekommt sogar eine eigene
kreditaufnahme möglichkeit ohne
festgelegte tilgungsfristen jedenfalls
noch nicht und ohne anrechnung auf die
verfassungsrechtlichen
schuldenobergrenzen nur darum geht es
nur darum wurde diese konstruktion
gewählt schon seit 2020 setzt die
regierung die schuldenbremse immer
wieder ausnahmsweise aus und nutzt die
mittel auch noch zweckentfremdet das ist
permanente rechtsbruch rechtsbruch den
aber irgendwie außer der afg jemanden
stört und auch heute ist wieder eine
zweckentfremdung der mittel angelegt
denn diese dürfen nach dem gesetzentwurf
mit dem namen bundeswehr
sondervermögens gesetz leider nicht nur
zugunsten der bundeswehr sondern auch
für die aufrüstung von nicht näher
definierten partnerstaaten ausgegeben
werden § 2 all das ist überflüssig und
intransparent der kernhaushalt spiegelt
so zunehmend nur noch einen teil der
wirklichkeit die sozialisten und
umverteilen hier im haus werden das
begrüßen denn natürlich regiert sie es
mit verschleierten und ausgelagerten
schulden viel einfacher zu machen sie es
ja auch schon beim klima vor beim esm
und bei den eu schulden programm wegen
der kausalkette von der schuld
modernisierung der ezb zu hoher
inflation ist das aber fatal wir haben
soziale 7 teuerungen die waffen die dann
ab frühestens sommer frühestens im
herbst oder nächstes jahr über nächstes
jahr aus dem sondervermögen finanziert
werden wer denn den ausgang des ukraine
kriegs nicht beeinflussen die ukraine
krieg dient zwar als anlass für ein
umsteuern bei der seit jahren
vernachlässigten ausstattung der
bundeswehr die notwendigkeit dafür ist
jedoch uralt und keine kriegsfolgen
ukraine überhaupt nicht
wer etwas anderes behauptet und eben
doch einen bezug zur ukraine herstellt
und das ist ja eben hier reichlich schon
geschehen der liegt nicht nur
haushalterisch falsch frau wenn es darin
lambrecht und herr dobrindt sie haben
sich ja nach pressemitteilung heutigen
einigt auf schwere waffenlieferungen das
ging ja auch alles ganz ohne
sondervermögen es geht es geht ohne
sondervermögen nicht nur hausen
ätherisch lieben sie darum falsch
sondern sie sollten dann auch erklären
dass man die jahrzehntealte deutsche
staatsdoktrin aufgeben will keine waffen
in kriegsgebiete zu liefern das aber
wäre dann für deutschland nicht nur ein
haushalt eric schweitzer sondern
zugleich ein hochgefährlicher weg
herzlichen dank
gitta böhringer hier mit seiner kritik
am vorhaben der ampelkoalition 100
milliarden euro sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr auszugeben für die
bundesregierung spricht nun die
außenministerin anna lena hartberg
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen das ist eine
besondere debatte heute und auch die
finale lösung führt eine besondere
lesung sein nicht nur angesichts dieses
furchtbaren krieges den die vorredner
bereits angesprochen haben nicht nur
weil wir dich jeden tag hier eine
grundgesetz änderung vornehmen sondern
weil viele menschen viele hauptstädte in
europa aber auch darüber hinaus auf uns
schauen bei diesem sondervermögen geht
es eben nicht nur um 100 milliarden hier
bei uns sondern es geht auch um unsere
zukünftige verantwortung in europa und
in unserem gemeinsamen bündnis es geht
um die zukünftige sicherheit von uns die
sicherheit zukünftiger generationen und
die sicherheit unserer bündnispartner
und ihrer zukünftigen
generationen denn unsere bündnispartner
haben uns erst ermöglicht hier in
unserem land in den letzten jahrzehnten
in frieden aufzuwachsen
generationen die meinung in
westdeutschland ein ganzes dank im
friedensprojekt europa unsere partner
haben in den letzten jahrzehnten viel in
unsere sicherheit investiert dafür sind
wir dankbar und zeitenwende bedeutet
auch dass wir nicht nur dankbar sind
sondern dass wir das in dem moment wo
andere investitionen von uns in ihre
sicherheit brauchen jetzt zurückgeben
und daher ist es für uns wirklich
entscheidend dass wir dieses
sondervermögen eben nicht nur definieren
und eben nicht nur im grundgesetz
definieren für unsere streitkräfte
sondern unsere bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit und genau darauf
schauen viele menschen eben nicht nur in
deutschland sondern in ganz europa ob
wir unser bündnis verantwortung gerecht
werden und ich möchte noch mal
unterstreichen dass vorrednerin und
vorredner und so habe ich auch sie
verstanden herr dobrindt gesagt haben
dass es kein moment für parteitaktische
spielchen und wenn wir ehrlich sind und
alle die ehrlich zu sich selbst sein
können hat jede partei jede fraktion
hier ihr päckchen zu tragen
das wichtige ist doch das was man in der
vergangenheit vielleicht nicht erkannt
hat in zukunft richtig zu machen und
zwar gemeinsam und deswegen ist eine
endrunde
änderung auf eine gemeinsame
verantwortung
wir haben das in diesem hohen haus schon
öfter gemacht damals in anderen rollen
opposition und regierung zusammen als
europa und brauchte in der eurokrise
nicht auf uns alleine zu schauen als
fraktion und als parteien sondern unsere
verantwortung deutschlands in europa und
es freut mich sehr dass wir
signalisiert bekommen haben dass wir
diesen weg jetzt gemeinsam geben sie hat
ein paar fragen angesprochen paar stehen
ja auch in der zeitung auf die ich
ergänzen zu dem was meine kollegen schon
gesagt haben gerne eingehen möchte der
eine punkt ist die frage von aufrüstung
und ausrüstung ich glaube dass es kein
gegensatz sondern das gehört ganz denkt
miteinander zusammen vor lamprecht die
verteidigungsministerin hat das bereits
angesprochen wenn wir im baltikum sind
dann wissen wir wir müssen in zukunft
mehr tun an der ostflanke aber wenn man
da vor ort ist und dann zugleich hört
man wagt sich das ja vielleicht gar
nicht auszusprechen die soldatinnen und
soldaten auf der tribüne und wissen das
und gehen jeden tag mit dieser
herausforderung um dann können wir eben
nicht einfach nur sagen wir verstärken
jetzt unsere enhance vorweg presents in
der battle groups sondern dann brauchen
wir dafür eben auch die ausrüstung und
wenn man dann sieht dass die ozelot
yvonne jahr angesprochen worden sind in
der battle group derzeit
verankert sind zugleich aber eben auch
in der etf der nato gemeldet sind da
müssen wir einfach sagen wir können die
dinge nicht zwei mal melden sondern dann
müssen wir mehr in die ausrüstung
eingeben und das gleiche gilt für den
digitalen funk und sie lachen da wenn
man jetzt eine übung gemacht und wir
sind die lead nation und das ist nicht
verschlüsselt dann haben wir eine riesen
herausforderung und die wird ein
zweistelligen milliardenbetrag kosten
und deswegen ist es für uns wichtig dass
wir vor allem auch in die
ausrüstungsdefizite der vergangenheit
gemeinsam jetzt investieren
und das gleiche gilt das gleiche gilt
dass wir eben nicht den luxus haben zu
sagen ostflanke oder nato fähigkeiten
oder
internationale einsätze alles gehört in
dieser komplexen welt miteinander
zusammen wir tragen auch weiterhin eine
verantwortung im rahmen der vereinten
nationen peacekeeping und da haben wir
das gleiche problem for lambs
angesprochen 51 tiger kampfhubschrauber
eigentlich könnten es uns ganz einfach
machen und sagen wenn die franzosen
gehen dann stellen wir kampfhubschrauber
leider funktionieren aber nur neun von
den 51 deswegen ist der weg eben nicht
so einfach und deswegen müssen wir uns
jetzt den kopf zerbrechen wie wir in der
vn mission bleiben können und auch dafür
dient das sondervermögen damit wir in
zukunft unserer internationalen
verantwortung auch dort in den vereinten
nationen gerecht werden
und ich freue mich sehr dass ich hier so
eine ernsthafte debatte führen und danke
auch bei mir aus einem
sicherheitspolitiker in der union wir
haben ja schon viel darüber gesprochen
weil zeit für pappkameraden ist es nicht
ich möchte es hier trotzdem noch einmal
sagen weil in der öffentlichkeit ich
manchmal diese argumente hören es geht
bei diesem sondervermögen nicht um
humanitäre hilfe die ist absolut
notwendig dafür stellen wir aber einen
ergänzungs haushalt auf es geht hier um
karte
sicherheitsmaßnahmen im sinne der
vernetzten sicherheit im sinne der nato
anrechenbarkeit von den fähigkeiten die
wir leisten müssen aber sie haben gesagt
warum stehen da nicht die zwei prozent
im gesetzentwurf war dann würden wir
sich auch ins grundgesetz schreiben und
wollen wir jedes jahr wirklich zwei
prozent investieren was es in dem jahr
wo wir die f35 was es was es in dem jahr
über die f35 kaufen da sind es
vielleicht mehr als zwei prozent wollen
sie denn das grundgesetz an diesem tag
ändern und in dem jahr wurde nach
weniger ist wollen sie es dann wieder
ändern nein das was wir wachsen ist ein
aktion unser nachwuchs verpflichtung
gerecht werden unsere nach der
verpflichtung gerecht werden und
zugleich mit dem sondervermögen die
lücken zu schließen die leider in der
vergangenheit gerissen worden sind und
ein letzter satz dazu ein letzter satz
dazu warum die debatte so wichtig ist
wir haben auch erlebt es geht nicht nur
um immer mehr geld was wir sehen warum
wir manche lücken haben ist ein
beschaffungswesen und vor allem ein
bewirtschaftungs wesen wo man sich jetzt
fragt warum passt die eine panzer
schraube eigentlich nicht zur anderen
panzer schraube auch das sind dinge die
wir in dieser debatte gemeinsam angehen
müssen dass es hart dass es ernsthaft
aber das ist die verantwortung unserer
zeit für unsere generation für
zukünftige generationen in europa und
zwar nicht nur in deutschland sondern
für alle in europa nord und süd und west
und ost herzlichen dank und freue mich
auf die weiteren sprachen
soweit die bundes außenministerin
annalena baerbock hat hier auch nochmal
von den staaten sicherheitspolitischen
belangen gesprochen für die dieses
sondervermögen sein soll auch das
fordert die union dass dieses
sondervermögen nicht für weiche belange
ausgegeben wird das wird die nächste
rednerin anders sehen amira mohammed ali
für die linksfraktion
wege der präsidentin kolleginnen und
kollegen der völkerrechtswidrigen krieg
putins bringt unvorstellbares leid für
die menschen in der ukraine bei uns in
deutschland wächst die angst dass sich
dieser krieg ausweiten könnte die
konsequenz die die bundesregierung aber
aus diesem schrecklichen krieg zieht
nämlich ein sondervermögen in höhe von
100 milliarden euro für das militär
bereitzustellen diese konsequenz ist
absolut falsch
denn das für den krieg in der ukraine
nicht beenden und es wird auch nicht zu
mehr sicherheit für uns führen dass
einzigen sowas es führen wird ist dass
die aktienkurse der rüstungskonzerne in
die höhe gehen dass dort die profite
steigen das ist die wahrheit aber
kolleginnen und kollegen diesen irrsinn
werden wir als linke nicht mitmachen
fakt ist
bereits heute gäben die nato staaten
mehr als das 17-fache ist das militär
aus weißrussland das tut und das hat
putin nicht abgeschreckt er trotzdem
diesen schrecklichen krieg begonnen wie
kommt man darauf dass noch mehr geld
fürs deutsche militär irgendetwas ändern
sollte und russland ist eine atommacht
da wollen wir dich mal erinnern wer
glaubt das wettrüsten geht zu einer
entspannung der lage beiträgt der ist
einfach im irrtum kollegen verlangen
noch nie in der geschichte der
menschheit hat ein wettrüsten frieden
und sicherheit gebracht im gegenteil wir
uns mal 1983 die älteren werden sich
erinnern darf ist eine falschmeldung
über ein us atom schlag gegen die udssr
und ein atomkrieg ist nur deswegen
vermieden worden weil ein sowjetischer
offizier
befehlsverweigerung begangen hat denken
sie mal daran
fakt ist auch schon heute kommt
deutschland jedes jahr mehr und mehr ins
militär aktuell 50 milliarden euro zum
vergleich das medien senioren frauen und
jugend gibt es gerade mal ein viertel
davon nämlich 13 milliarden und sie
behaupten jetzt die bundeswehr die
bräuchten noch mehr geld um endlich
einsatzfähig zu werden das falsch die
bundeswehr ist nicht wegen zu wenig geld
kaum einsatzfähig sondern wegen des
grottenschlechten managements das ist
die wahrheit
ein beispiel
210 millionen euro wurden ausgegeben für
sturmgewehre die im einsatz nicht gerade
aus schießen können und die firma
heckler & koch die musste dafür nicht
mal schadenersatz leisten weil die
kaufverträge so ausgestaltet waren dass
sie dafür nicht haften der kolleginnen
und kollegen wer verhandelt denn solche
verträge und in diese schwarze noch in
dieses marco fritz und heta oder drei
weitere milliarden steuergelder versenkt
werden nein erklären sie erst mal wohin
die viel milliarden bisher geflossen
sind herr scholz
mit diesen 100 milliarden euro könnte
man sehr vieles sinnvolles tun dieses
geld würde reichen alle schulen in
deutschland zu sanieren und alle maroden
brücken um straßen zu modernisieren und
dazu läuft alle rentnerinnen und
rentnern ein würdevolles leben im alter
zu ermöglichen bedeutet die renten als
feste mindestrenten und auch noch
zusätzlich könnte man allen kindern in
allen schulen und kitas jeden tag ein
kostenloses mittagessen zur verfügung
stehen das wären 100 milliarden euro
möglich aber daran denken
die versprochene pflege bonus der ist
übrigens auch noch nicht ausgezahlt
worden und ich frage mich wirklich was
ist das eigentlich für eine
verantwortungslose politik klein zu
versprechen werden nicht eingehalten
aber nun sollen 100 milliarden euro
zusätzlich für flugzeuge wachende kraft
wohnen und panzer locker gemacht werden
ich finde das wirklich unglaublich und
sie müssen sich überhaupt nicht darüber
wundern dass immer mehr menschen im land
nicht einmal mehr zur wahl gehen weil
sie jedes vertrauen in politik verloren
haben aber eines
kann ich ihnen sagen ja ich kann
verstehen dass sie das sehr ungern hören
ist aber die wahrheit eines möchte ich
ihnen noch sagen wir als linke die
soziale position in diesem land wir
werden ihnen das nicht durchgehen lassen
dankeschön
wir sind aber hier und wir konnten auch
hier seien unverschämtheit
amira mohammed ali den zwischenruf
konnten wir nun nicht verstehen aber
wahrscheinlich zählt er darauf ab dass
die linke zwar die fünf prozent hürde
nicht geschafft hat aber durch die
direktmandate diese erlangt hat ja auch
im bundestag sitzt eine kurzintervention
aus den reihen der echte
gegen
die bundeswehr unsere streitkräfte
ein schwarzes loch genannt ich möchte ja
persönlich erklären ich schäme mich
dafür dass in diesem hause so über
unsere bundeswehr in anwesenheit von
vertretern der bundeswehr gesprochen
wird sie verteidigen das territorium sie
verteidigen das bündnis sie sind kein
schwarzes loch sie sind die garantie für
unsere sicherheit herzlichen dank
marco buschmann je bundesjustizminister
ist hier in die reihen der abgeordneten
gegangen um sein recht einer
kurzintervention wahrnehmen zu können
gehts ja herr kollege buschmann das habe
ich nicht gesagt ich habe vom etat
gesprochen und es ist eine tatsache dass
wegen missmanagements das ist ein grund
warum unsere soldaten soldaten keine
vernünftige ausrüstung haben worum es
nicht genug warme socken gibt finden sie
das respektvoll hier muss man auch erst
mal hinschauen wo das geld hingeflossen
ist und dass sie das geld was ich
kritisiere habe dafür ist zu
metallisierten wollen zu behaupten ich
hätte keinen respekt vor der bundeswehr
sei eine unverschämtheit genossen die
genossen von mir sind in der bundeswehr
lasse mir nicht nachsagen danke
soweit also die kurzintervention die der
bundesjustizminister als abgeordneter
gestellt hat deswegen aus den reihen
seiner fraktion und die erwiderung von
amira mohammed badie es geht weiter in
der debatte mit karsten klein für die
fdp-fraktion er sitzt im
haushaltsausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die situation
die die ampel am anfang dieser
legislaturperiode bei der bundeswehr vor
gefunden hat war eine situation die von
großen defiziten da hat mit großen
defiziten behaftet war beim thema
ausstattung ausrüstung motivation und
anerkennung der soldatinnen und soldaten
aber vor allem auch liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der union nach 16 jahren
unions kanzlerschaft beim
abschreckungspotenzial unserer grund
streitkräfte und um die in der aktuellen
internationalen lage und auch gerade die
situation in der ukraine hat diesen
blick noch einmal geschärft auf diese
enormen defizite und wir in der
koalition die ampel hat auch schon erste
schritte eingeleitet um genau diese
defizite abzustellen im gegensatz zu dem
was herr kollege dobrindt hier behauptet
hat haben wir die mittel in dieser
legislaturperiode schon um zehn
milliarden euro angehoben für die
ausrüstung im kernhaushalt der bundes
werden erste reformschritte sind auch
bei der bundeswehr schon ergriffen
worden und das beschaffungswesen zu
verbessern wir haben zum ersten mal in
der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland eine bewaffnung für drohnen
auf den weg gebracht und wir haben 2,4
milliarden euro für die vollausstattung
der soldatinnen und soldaten auf dem weg
gebracht eine enorme leistung und ein
respektvolles zeichen an unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten dass sie haben
fehler in der letzten legislaturperiode
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und jetzt bringt diese koalition mit dem
sondervermögen mit 100 milliarden euro
einen turbo lift auf dem weg um aus
dieser situation herauszukommen und wir
freien demokraten wir fordern schwere
waffen auch für die ukraine
aber uli kollege dobrindt wer schwere
waffen für die bundeswehr für die
ukraine fordert er muss sie auch der
bundeswehr können viele projekte die
ihre verteidigungsministerien
angekündigt haben zum beispiel die nach
das nachfolgeprojekt zum tornado war
doch niemals durchfinanziert im
verteidigungshaushalt das ermöglicht
jetzt dieses sondervermögen deshalb
erwarte ich dass sie zu diesen
sondervermögen zustimmen
in dieser historischen situation liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der union
sollten sie sich ihrer verantwortung
stellen gegenüber der soldatinnen und
soldaten der bundeswehr gegenüber den
menschen in diesem land und gegenüber
den kindern in diesem land denn die
werden irgendwann ihnen mal die frage
stellen wo sie waren wo standen sie in
der situation in dieser historischen
situation wo es darum ging dass wir die
verteidigungsfähigkeit der
bundesregierung dieses landes
wiederherstellen können wo waren sie in
dieser situation lieber union und
deshalb die ampel setzt mit dem
sondervermögen die voraussetzung diese
verteidigungsfähigkeit das
abschreckungspotenzial
wiederherzustellen
wir strecken ihnen die hand aus
ergreifen sie diese hand nicht für uns
von der ampel nicht für sie wie ich das
auch einigen reihen von ihnen schon
gehört hat sondern für die menschen für
den frieden und freiheit in europa in
deutschland und auch in der ukraine
vielen dank
für die cdu csu fraktion hat nun dr
matthias mittelberg das wort
geschätzte frau präsidentin weil eben
kolleginnen und kollegen ich möchte mal
das aufgreifen was die beiden
bundesministerinnen hier angesprochen
haben wir haben ja eine sehr ernste
debatte
und wir erleben eine zeitenwende die wir
wahrscheinlich alle nicht so gerne
erlebt hätten und
es ist richtig was der bundeskanzler
gesagt hat vor gut acht wochen hier von
diesem pult frau woche hat eben
angesprochen wir müssten uns alle ein
stück weit bewegen aber wenn wir jetzt
mal die letzten die diskussion der
letzten wochen vor dem geistigen auge
passieren lassen und wenn man jetzt die
diskussion um das sondervermögen
verfolgen dann muss ich doch feststellen
dass meine fraktion sich eigentlich am
wenigsten bewegen muss wir liegen
nämlich voll auf der linie des
bundeskanzlers also wenn wir das jetzt
mal ganz ernst sehen und da erkenne ich
auch sehr an dass sich hier viele bewegt
haben gerade sie frau baerbock ich sage
dass jahren erkennt das ist alles in
ordnung das ist auch richtig so aber
wenn es um die feststellung geht dann
müssen sie vor allen dingen dafür sorge
tragen dass in ihrer eigenen fraktion
und der bundeskanzler muss dafür sorge
tragen dass sind seiner fraktion sich
die leute auf ihn zu bewegen auf seine
position denn da werden seine position
die er vor acht wochen hier
ausgesprochen hat eben gerade nicht
geteilt wird ihnen das gleich noch genau
sagen
schon vor lamprecht das stand b40 frau
lambrecht hat hier gesagt man müsse den
begriff zweiten wenn die jetzt mit
substanz füllen und hat sich an unsere
fraktion gewandt das war jetzt aber
wirklich ein scherz vollem recht das
kann ja gar nicht ernst gemeint sagt das
kann nicht ernst gemeint sein also wenn
einer das was der bundeskanzler hier vor
acht wochen klar und deutlich
angekündigt hat wenn einer das wirklich
zu 100 prozent erfüllen will dann ist
das diese bundestagsfraktion von cdu und
csu
aber wirklich zu 100 prozent
der bundeskanzler hat hier von einem
sondervermögen bundeswehr gesprochen
nicht von einem sondervermögen
sicherheit oder bündnisfähigkeit oder
irgendwas sondern von einem
sondervermögen bundeswehr und deswegen
legen wir wert darauf auch schon was die
formulierung im grundgesetz angeht dass
klargestellt ist dass diese mittel die
wir hierfür extra und außerordentlich
freigeben dass die dann am ende auch bei
unseren streitkräften bei unserer
bundeswehr land und diese stärkung der
bundeswehr als auch der stärkste und
beste beitrag zur stärkung unserer
bündnisfähigkeit und
ich will ihnen gerne glauben vor
baerbock was sie gesagt haben aber es
gibt hier auch andere aussagen von
leuten hier in diesem parlament die
nicht ganz unwichtig sind beispielsweise
der spd-fraktionsvorsitzende kollege
mützenich er hat ihr vor einigen wochen
in der generaldebatte fast das gegenteil
dessen erklärt was der kanzler gesagt
hat es ging nämlich darum hat die
bereiche humanitäre hilfe
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
abrüstung genannt und die sagte er
wortwörtlich wir wollen diese bereiche
genauso bestärkt sehen wie die
investitionen in die bundeswehr
angesichts dessen und angesichts auch
der ankündigung vom kollegen klar hier
zivile krisenprävention und andere dinge
aus den mitteln zu finanzieren haben wir
manifeste zweifel ob sie wirklich die
mittel zur stärkung der bundeswehr
verwenden wollen und ob sie die wirklich
zu verstärken auch der bündnisfähigkeit
verwenden wollen das sage ich ganz
deutlich und deswegen legen wir wert auf
klare formulierung schon im grundgesetz
das was sie heute hier in den bundestag
eingebracht haben ist so für uns nicht
zustimmungsfähig
und
ich sage nein letzte
ja ich sage ganz genau so wie es heute
formuliert ist so wie es heute hier
eingebracht ist so wie es jetzt vorliegt
ist es nicht zustimmungsfähig so wir
haben einen weiteren punkt nämlich die 2
prozent von denen der bundeskanzler
ausdrücklich gesprochen hat er hat
ausdrücklich den satz gesagt von von nun
an jahr für jahr mehr als zwei prozent
des bruttoinlandsprodukts in unsere
verteidigung zu investieren klare
aussage des bundeskanzlers da müssen wir
uns keinen millimeter auf ihn zu bewegen
da sind wir voll auf der linie des
bundeskanzlers da unterstützen wir ihn
zu 100 prozent klare aussage von herrn
mütze nicht ich zitiere jetzt auch die
spd ist nach wie vor der auffassung dass
zur kriegs verhinderung mehr gehört als
immer größere rüstungsausgaben und schon
gar nicht gehört dazu nachfolgenden
generationen vorzuschreiben wie hoch
diese ausgaben zu sein haben
entschuldigung wenn ich feststelle dass
ist das exakte gegenteil dessen was der
bundeskanzler hier gesagt habe
und wir legen schon
wenn sie es mit einer zeitenwende
wirklich ernst meinen dass wir das dann
hier auch gesetzgeberisch exekutieren
wir stehen dafür zur verfügung aber wir
stehen wirklich auch für lösungen zur
verfügung die das umsetzen was der
bundeskanzler hier vor acht wochen
gesagt hat angekündigt hat dazu haben
wir haben wir applaudiert aus
überzeugung aber wir wollen das dann
auch konsequent so umgesetzt wissen
mathias middelberg der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der unionsfraktion
war das hier in der ersten beratung zum
bundeswehr sondervermögen der wird es
einerseits um die änderung des
grundgesetzes und dann auch um den
gesetzentwurf um dieses sondervermögen
einzurichten achim post spricht jetzt
für die spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
jede debatte im deutschen bundestag ist
wichtig zweifelsohne aber nicht in jeder
debatte im deutschen bundestag geht es
um grundlegende ja historische
weichenstellung so wie heute und
deswegen sollte man sich sollten sich
alle hier sollten wir alle hier über
das nachdenken über das reden worum es
wirklich geht es geht um ein
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr es
geht darum die bundeswehr zu ertüchtigen
zu verstärken und handlungsfähiger zu
machen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und das ist es wert darüber ganz in ruhe
ganze ist ganz ordentlich zu
respektieren
wenn wir wissen doch alle wir wissen
doch alle der krieg in der ukraine ist
ein krieg gegen das ukrainische volk
einen krieg gegen die menschlichkeit und
verantwortlich dafür sind nur putin und
seine schergen und sonst niemand liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und wir sind hier einige vor inderinnen
vor ihnen haben es angesprochen wir sind
in einer situation
wahrscheinlich die schwierigste
sicherheitspolitische bedrohungslage für
deutschland und für ganz europa seit
1945 da sollten wir uns auch in der
debatte mal messing und nicht so tun als
wüsste man alles besser herr mittelberg
und hätte alles von vornherein togo muss
dann würde ich ein bisschen vorsichtiger
sein wenn die puppe auch die riege der
verteidigungsministerium vertreter der
cdu drei viertel der
verteidigungsminister in der
bundesrepublik deutschland wird nämlich
ihre partei an also ein bisschen mehr
demut wäre angebracht wo kolleginnen
kollegen und
und es gekapert
putins aggression
putins aggression wird zweierlei
ja er will die ukraine erobern und zwar
komplett aber er will auch die
demokratie beschädigen schwächen kleiner
machen und deshalb liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen bin ich dafür dass wir haltung
zeigen dass wir uns stark machen mit
unseren werten mit unseren überzeugungen
und mit unserem zusammenhalt das ist ja
auch ein wichtiger punkt der in einer
solch schwierigen lage liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen und deshalb lieber kollege
und kollegen sagen ich mal 1
ich habe genau zugehört bei dem was der
bundeskanzler gesagt hat wir uns auch
bei dem was man in fraktionsvorsitzender
rolf mützenich gesagt hat vor acht
wochen und auch bei dem was der
fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu csu gesagt
habe und ich darf sie zitieren herr merz
sie haben gesagt ja liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen das war eine gute
regierungserklärung das ist doch mal ein
satz mit dem kann ich arbeiten mit dem
können wir alle arbeiten liebe kollegen
regen das finde ich dass man eine sehr
die regierungserklärung das war eine
sehr gute regierungserklärung des
bundeskanzlers und deshalb und deshalb
machen sie doch weiter so machen sie
weiter so bei solchen sätzen mit solchen
klaren sätzen und versuchen sie das was
wir versuchen alexander dobrindt hat es
doch versuchen denn so nachrede
natürlich können wir in diesem haus und
natürlich werden wir in diesem hause
darüber reden wie das geld für die
bundeswehr ausgegeben wird sinnvoll
ausgegeben wird und natürlich werden wir
darüber reden wie wir tilgung
organisieren und natürlich werden wir
darüber reden über parlamentarische
kontrolle richtig machen und fertig
organisieren die in diesem hause und
deshalb zusammengefasst
deshalb sollten deshalb zu sorgen
deshalb zusammengefasst das angebot
meiner fraktion am sie ist ganz klar wir
möchten dass sie mitmachen bei einem
überparteilichen
grundkonsens für die sicherheitspolitik
in der bundesrepublik deutschland und
wir haben ein klares angebot auf den
tisch gelegt und deshalb bedanke ich
mich noch mal an dieser stelle bei der
bundesregierung beim bundeskanzler bei
christian lindner bei annalena baerbock
und bei christine lambrecht für das was
sie in den letzten wochen nach vorne
gebracht haben bei diesem grundlegenden
sicherheitspolitischen projekt und ganz
am schluss
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
cdu csu ganz am schluss muss man sich
entscheiden man muss sich in solchen
debatten entscheiden was man will will
man konstruktiv mit magen ich nehme den
einen oder anderen war dass er das will
will man konstruktiv mitmachen oder herr
merz wenn man bei dem bleiben was ich
beim letzten mal gesagt habe als sie
nicht da haben sie müssen sich
entscheiden was sie wollen staatstheater
oder staatsräson
soweit adrian post auf ihn folgt nun
michael espendiller für die fdp-fraktion
er sitzt im haushaltsausschuss für die
afg fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen liebe zuschauer im
saal und bei youtube ich habe neulich
eine sehr treffende kurzanalyse über
unser land gelesen darin hieß es
deutschland dem wahrnehmung seiner
sicherheits interesse an die nato
outsourced seine produktion in china und
seine energiegewinnung an russland und
natürlich ist das jetzt etwas
vereinfacht dargestellt aber es trifft
doch ziemlich ins schwarze denn unser
land ist in existenziellen fragen von
anderen nationen abhängig insofern
begrüßen wir dass diese bundesregierung
jetzt endlich aufgewacht ist und
begreift wie dringend notwendig eine
adäquat ausgestattete bundeswehr für die
sicherheit und souveränität unseres
landes ist den eingeschlagenen weg
hierfür 100 milliarden euro neue
schulden zu machen und nicht endlich
einmal den rotstift bei der
ausgabenpolitik anzusetzen kritisieren
wir allerdings deutlich sie hätten auch
einfach den veritas dauerhaft erhöhen
können das wäre haushalterisch sauber
und den bürgern gegenüber ehrlicher
insofern
insofern kann sich den ausführungen
eines kollegen peter böhringer
umfänglich zustimmen was ist darüber aus
noch beschäftigt ist natürlich das
beschaffungswesen egal ob sturmgewehre
transporthubschrauber tankschiffe oder
die noble restaurierung der gorch fock
in der deutschen öffentlichkeit herrscht
die meinung vor dass die bundeswehr in
sachen beschaffung ein fass ohne boden
ist und das steuergeld auf
nimmerwiedersehen verschwindet und der
kollege buschmann bevor sie sich dann
wieder aufregen es ist hier steuergeld
das ist nicht unser gipfel müsse auf
jeden euro achten eine reform des
beschaffungswesens daher dringend
erforderlich
das haben wir die letzte legislatur
immer wieder angemahnt und diese
forderung erhalten wir auch nach wie vor
aufrecht allerdings muss der ehrlichkeit
halber auch gesagt werden neben dem
beschaffungswesen ist auch immer wieder
unterschiedliche zielkonflikte die
militärische beschaffungs projekte
belastet haben und einer der größten
zeichnet sich auch jetzt wieder beim
sondervermögen ab es ist absolut
nachvollziehbar dass die bundesregierung
angesichts der aktuellen lage auf markt
verfügbare fertige produkte setzt um die
bundeswehr schnellst möglich keit stadt
fähig zu machen doch das bedeutet
aktuell dass deutschland im bereich der
größten rüstungsvorhaben vornehmlich auf
produkte aus übersee sitzt
beispielsweise der tornado nachfolger
soll die amerikanische f 35 von lockheed
martin während und nach aktuellen
berichten will die bundesregierung auf
60 china hubschrauber der amerikanischen
firma boeing kaufen der euro fällt
weiter von dem auch ein paar wenige auf
der einkaufsliste stehen wird immerhin
noch in deutschland gebaut doch das kann
nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen dass beim
sondervermögen die standortpolitik und
das bekenntnis zur deutschen wirtschaft
gar keine rolle spielt nochmals auch wir
sehen die notwendigkeit eines
konsequenten handelns bei der ausrüstung
der bundeswehr klar und deutlich was
muss auch gesagt werden dass wir uns mit
dem von der regierung ins auge gefasste
projekte in neue abhängigkeiten begeben
und uns damit finanziell auf jahrzehnte
hinaus festlegen wir befürchten dass es
mit dem sondervermögen zu eine weitere
verlust wert technischer fähigkeiten in
deutschland kommt und damit auch zu
einem weiteren verlust von
arbeitsplätzen und schlussendlich auch
von deutscher souveränität der auch die
bundestagsfraktion will das gütesiegel
made in germany und die souveränität
dieses landes gehalten und dafür werden
wir uns in den beratungen bei einsatz
[Applaus]
die beiden gesetzentwürfe werden nach
dieser debatte an die entsprechenden
ausschüsse überwiesen und der
haushaltsausschüsse wird diese
federführend beraten und so ist auch der
nächste redner hier ein
haushaltspolitiker sven christian
kindler von bündnis 90 die grünen meine
damen und herren die welt ist seit dem
schrecklichen angetrieben russlands auf
die ukraine eine andere damit wurden
drei jahrzehnte europäische friedens
sicherheitsarchitektur aufgekündigt und
zwar einseitig durch die brutale in
version von wladimir putin und deswegen
stellen sich für uns jetzt in
deutschland viele sicherheitspolitische
außenpolitische fragen neu für mich
unsere fraktion natürlich müssen wir
auch klären welche aufgaben welche
funktionen welche möglichkeiten nur die
bundeswehr jetzt und in zukunft auch
haben deswegen ist unsere fraktion auch
sehr klar wir brauchen diesen zeiten
eine gut ausgestattete bunten bundeswehr
und wir brauchen diesen zeiten einen
stärken unser bundestrainer
verteidigungsfähigkeit genau dafür dient
diese sondervermögen
und klar ist das natürlich
sicherheitspolitik in diesen zeiten auch
eine vernetzte sicherheitspolitik sein
muss man diesen sicherheitsbegriff hat
noch nicht diese neue regierung auf
unten das war schon auch ein
sicherheitsbegriff den auch die alte
regierung unter kanzlerin merkel
verfolgt hat den übrigens auch die nato
verfolgt denn es war schon immer so das
nato ausgaben eingerechnet wurden
natürliche streitkräfte betreffen aber
auch darüber hinaus das machen sehr
viele länder in der nato auch genau so
und deswegen weil es ja auch sinnvoll
ist werde leben gerade viele
cyber-angriffe auf deutschland auf
windenergie anlagen auch kritische
infrastruktur und natürlich ist klar die
abhängigen cyber sicherheit ist in
unserem sicherheitsinteresse und daran
müssen wir investieren
und die außenminister das angesprochen
natürlich brauchen wir auch einen
modernen digital punkt in deutschland
bei der bundeswehr brauchen moderne
verschlüsselungstechnik für unsere
sicherheitsinstitutionen
die ertüchtigung von partner starten wie
die waffenlieferung zb auch an ihm
kleine sind werden geliefert nicht aus
dem etat des bundeswehr sind aber
natürlich anrechenbar an der rahmen der
nato am grill quote und dieses
bundeswehr die sondervermögen
verbündeten verteidigungsfähigkeit
sollen eben die ausgaben die unter den a
tec gruppe fallen auch mit einbeziehen
und ich will noch einmal sagen auch zur
union zu einem mittelberg
krisenprävention stabilisierung und
friedensförderung vom auswärtigen amt
umformen
bundesentwicklungsministerium waren auch
in der regierung merkel schon an
rechnungs fähigkeit und eine quote grund
wurden auch von der regierung merkel
nach brüssel die nato gemeldet und ich
verstehe nicht wie das jetzt
und ich würde mir einfach wünschen wenn
ich mir die verteidigungsminister
minister der letzten jahre anschaut
franz josef jung karl theodor zu
guttenberg thomas de maizière ursula von
der leyen und annegret kramp-karrenbauer
das waren die verteidigungsministerium
minister der letzten 16 jahre der
bundesrat in dieser zeit erheblich auch
gestiegen von 2014 32 milliarden auf
jetzt 50 milliarden euro und die
bundesverteidigungsminister beschriebene
welcher bescheidenen zum teil desolate
lage die ausrüstungen ausstattung der
bundeswehr ist so bescheiden dass er
ganz wenig waffen jetzt aus den
beständen der bundeswehr auch geliefert
werden können und er würde ich mir schon
wünschen wenn sie hier sagen ein mit dem
berg wir sind die einzige fraktion die
sich bei diesem verfahren nicht bewegen
sollte ich würde mir mehr demut immer
selbstreflexion wünschen wenn wir auf
die letzten 16 jahre
verteidigungspolitik
denn worum es jetzt ja auch gehen muss
ist dass wir nicht über symbolischen
abstrakte quoten diskutieren sondern
darüber reden wie wir diese 100
milliarden euro sehr viel geld sind wie
wir die im sinnvoll ausgeben und
deswegen darf es hier auch keine
schnellschüsse geben sind wir waren sehr
konkrete entscheidung welche fähigkeiten
braucht die bundeswehr wer soll das
machen abstimmungen und europäischen
partnern mit abstimmen mit dem
bündnispartner in der nato nun ist auch
klar sein was macht deutschland was
machen andere partner das muss sehr gut
abgestimmt sein und am besten macht man
das in gemeinsamen projekten und davon
brauchen noch am besten ein
beschaffungswesen wie es in den letzten
16 jahren eben nicht wahr beim
beschaffungswesen dafür mit führt dass
wir sinnvoll geld einsetzen aber nicht
nach dividenden der rüstungsindustrie
erhöhen das kann ich das hier bei den
sondervermögen sein
und deswegen sind wir dafür dass es
komplexe und große beschaffungs projekte
darüber finanziert werden das wäre aber
auch das was ja schon begonnen wurde bei
der bundeswehr mit der task force auch
weiterführen das können erste schritte
seien noch lange nicht am ende das
schaffen gewesen bei der bundeswehr neu
aufzustellen nimmt am ende wirklich
sinnvolle beschaffungs projekte
organisiert werden und die konkrete
frage ist ja jetzt auch union und wir
begrüßen es sehr dass sie sich jetzt in
den gemeinsamen antrag der ampera
anschlüssen wir morgen sehr starkes
gemeinsames signal auch in deutschland
europa und in die welt senden dass wir
gemeinsam diesen da schon kleine
humanitär finanziell aber auch mit
waffen nicht vor unterstützen und die
frage an die ist
und ich wünsche mir sehr dass in den
nächsten wochen wie er in gemeinsamen
gesprächen auch dazu kommen bei den
sondervermögen zu einer gemeinsamen
lösung zu kommen das kabinett hat dafür
einen guten beschluss vorgelegt die
frage ist eben jetzt wollen sie hier in
die verantwortung gehen oder wird nach
parteitaktik bestimmen diese
entscheidung müssen sie treffen wir sind
zu gesprächen bereit vielen dank
sven christian kindler hat hier noch mal
darauf hingewiesen dass natürlich über
die projekte diskutiert werden muss die
finanziert werden sollen die 100
milliarden euro werden auch nicht in
diesem jahr als gesamtsumme aufgenommen
sondern über die kommenden jahre dann
immer wenn projekte finanziert werden
johann wadephul jetzt für die
unionsfraktion
damen und herren die unionsfraktion ist
das hat sie von anfang an gesagt in der
ersten debatte vor zwei monaten zu
konstruktiven gesprächen
über die von ihnen geplante
verfassungsänderung bereit und diese
bereitschaft besteht fort auch wenn die
heutige debatte eine einigung
schwieriger gemacht hat und das will ich
ihnen kurz erläutern wir müssen erst mal
sozusagen die sache von dem kopf auf die
füße stellen wenn sie wenn wir gemeinsam
der auffassung sind oder sie
insbesondere als regierungskoalition der
auffassung sind dass die bundeswehr mehr
geld benötigt dann haben sie das
haushaltsrechts ja mal eine mehrheit in
diesem haushalt sie haben einen
bundeskanzler dann verabschieden sie ein
bundeshaushalt mit ihrer mehrheit der
die bundeswehr hinreichend ausstattet es
ist ihre koalition es ist ihre mehrheit
haben sie jederzeit die möglichkeit dazu
wir sehen das nicht im haushalt
vorgesehen dass nirgendwo sie haben sich
entschlossen gemeinsam zu regieren alles
in ordnung wir sind in der opposition
wir kontrollieren das wie das aufgabe
der opposition ist aber sie haben
offensichtlich dazu nicht die
hinreichende kraft
und jetzt ja das will ich noch mal sagen
wenn das hier losgeht staatsraison
staatstheater da bin ich jetzt schon
fast bei vaterlandslose gesellen wenn
sie jetzt hier eine regelung aufstellen
wollen dass wir in jedem falle hier
zuzustimmen haben das ist nicht unsere
verantwortung wir bieten seit acht
wochen gespräche über die bundeswehr
über das beschaffungswesen über das was
sie anschaffen wollen über einen
tilgungsplan über eine formulierung im
deutschen grundgesetz kein einziges
gespräch hat mit mir als
verteidigungspolitiker hier
stattgefunden es hat heute ein zweites
gespräch gegeben es sind acht wochen
vergangen und wir lassen uns nicht mit
diesen markigen sprüchen unter druck
setzen alle diesen kollegen unterlegen
waren
thema die mich
es ist völlig klar dass die cdu csu
fraktion dass auch meine partei
eine verantwortung hat für den zustand
der bundeswehr das ist vollkommen klar
wir haben ja natürlich die abend 16
jahre dieses land regiert und wenn sie
den äußerungen eines
fraktionsvorsitzenden letzten tage mal
zugehört haben mit einem rückblick auch
zur verteidigungs und außenpolitik die
auch unser unter unserer verantwortung
geschehen ist dann ist da an
selbstkritik nicht
an selbstkritik nicht gemangelt und das
teilt meine fraktion friedrich merz hat
dazu richtige worte gefunden und wir
müssen das wir schauen uns das mit
selbstkritik an aber hier stehen herr
kollege tor so viele glashäuser und da
würde jeder gärtnereibetrieb vorüber
sein wir stehen sie setzten auch in
einem glashaus
2009 bis 2013 haben wir gemeinsam
miteinander regiert und herr fricke hat
von uns verlangt dass getötet
gemeinsam haben wir am stärksten gekürzt
bei der bundeswehr wir gemeinsam und die
fdp-fraktion afrika konzipiert das hat
keinen anlass hier irgendwie den
eindruck erweckt dass die fdp nicht an
der mitverantwortung hat
und ich muss sagen
die grüne fraktion hat ein ums andere
mal in der vergangenen legislaturperiode
klipp und klar gesagt dass zwei prozent
nie geht dass das eine und einer völlig
unverantwortliche festlegung gewesen ist
dass die grünen niemals zwei prozent
mittragen können und jetzt können wir
nicht schnell genug ihrer
verfassungsänderung mitteilen sie sitzen
auch im glashaus liebe grün seien sie
dann ebenso demütigen und was wirklich
und das muss ich sagen in aller
freundschaft auch kollege post aber
insbesondere frau
verteidigungsministerin
dass sie uns jetzt hier vor bieten wie
der zustand der bundeswehr ist schlägt
dem fass den boden aus schlägt dem fass
den boden aus ich habe in der letzten
legislaturperiode wie hier jeder weiß
das selbe amt bekleidet und mal um
halvar den haushaltsberatungen darum
gerungen dass wir mehr geld für die
bundeswehr bekommen im grunde mit ihren
worten und wer hat es verändern die
spd-finanzminister scholz hat eine
erhöhung nicht mitgetragen und die spd
fraktion hat sich gegen zwei prozent
gewann in diesem aus das ist ihre
verantwortung
und deswegen sagen wir
haben alle anlass auch das selbst
kritisch zu betrachten
nein entschuldigung dass wir sind wenn
wenn es doch ganz einfach wenn im
grundgesetz drinsteht dass das geld
wieder bundeskanzlers gesagt hat der hat
nicht von einem erweiterten
sicherheitsbegriff der richtig ist ein
kind ist doch vollkommen klar gesprochen
wird vom bundeswehr vermögen gesprochen
da hat der kollege mittelberg vorkommen
wenn ihm wenn drinsteht dass das für die
streitkräfte ist wenn es einen
tilgungsplan geht wenn es das gibt was
finanzminister linda zu recht gesagt hat
eine reform des beschaffungswesens und
wenn es eine einbindung der union bei
der verwendung der mittel das haben wir
von anfang an gesagt es gibt keinen
blankoscheck
wenn diese bedingungen mit uns endlich
mal besprochen werden dann wird man
darüber am ende reden können aber hier
sozusagen eine kommandoaktion zu machen
uns in der sache nicht zu beteiligen und
am ende zu sagen wir sind sozusagen
machen uhr staatstheater und würden der
staatsraison nicht gerecht werden das
werden wir nicht mitmachen so ist es und
danach folgt
johann wadephul hier mit deutlicher
kritik an den
ampelkoalition ihren und es gibt eine
kurzintervention aus den reihen der
grünen
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geschätzter kollege wadephul dass sie
meine frage nicht zugelassen haben was
ihr gutes recht ist versuche ich es mit
einer kurzintervention
ich schätze sie sehr das wissen sie auch
und wir kennen uns lange aus der
zusammenarbeit der letzten jahre im
parlament
ich möchte einen rat geben die fraktion
der union nicht auf eine parteitaktische
position festzulegen
und ihre argumentation zu beginn zu
beginn ihrer rede hervor ihre
argumentation war die sie sind jetzt in
der regierung
wir sind in der opposition
wenn sie glauben dass mehr geld für die
bundeswehr gebraucht wird stellen sie es
doch in den haushalt ein
und ich frage mich
wo ist die ernsthaftigkeit der lage wo
ist die ernsthaftigkeit der situation
sie können doch nicht ernsthaft mit uns
gemeinsam sagen wir sind seit dem 24
zwei dem angriffskrieg von putin auf die
ukraine mit allem was da dran hängt die
furchtbare situation
die gräueltaten die kriegsverbrechen die
tatsache dass die ukraine angewiesen ist
auf unterstützung
humanitär wirtschaftlich und
militärische mittel
und wir wissen wie desaströs die
ausstattung der bundeswehr ist und wir
wissen dass sie 16 jahre
die bundesminister der verteidigung
gestellt haben dann können sie sich doch
an diesem pult nicht einen so schlank
fußball und sagen sie sind regierung wir
sind opposition
regel sie die frage der sicherheit zum
friedensordnung die frage der
sicherheitsstandards und unserer
gemeinsamen verteidigungs und
bündnisfähigkeit alleine da habe ich und
sicher viele menschen dem land eine
andere erwartung an die union
kollege wadephul kollegen wie hole ich
bitte noch ein moment um geduld
ich bitte um einen moment um geduld ich
habe jetzt entschieden dass ich zwei
kurzinterventionen zu lassen sie dann
natürlich auch die doppelte zeit haben
zur erwiderung
das wort hat der kollege fricke zu einer
kurzintervention
herr kollege wartet wohl da ich wenig
von dem spruch halte suche nach dem
schuldigen das ist so typisch deutsch
sondern ich glaube im parlament muss man
nach lösungen suchen will ich zwei dinge
fest sein erstens sie haben mich richtig
zitiert weil ich ja nun lange schon
haushalt mache und ich deswegen auch
sagen das ist so an der stelle so sind
die zahlen und so sind die fakten und
jeder der hier im raum ist kann sich ja
mal fragen wie ihr abgestimmtes zweitens
ich möchte sie darauf hinweisen ich weiß
nicht ob sie in den gang ist oder ob das
im teil der rede so war der
finanzminister hat ausdrücklich gesagt
was in den letzten 15 jahren war er hat
ganz bewusst nicht gesagt was seit 2013
ihr passiert ist um auch hier nochmal
deutlich zu machen wo meine fraktion hin
will nämlich in dieser wichtigen zeit
dort wo wir eben keine
zweidrittelmehrheit haben zu einem
gemeinsamen ergebnis zu einer
gemeinsamen lösung zu kommen deswegen
zweitens habe ich eine bitte um antwort
wenn sie sagen mit ihnen hat niemand
gesprochen okay dann müssen wir gucken
dass wir sprechen ich habe auch ich
freue mich auch wenn ich mit meinem
kollegen haase haushaltspolitischer
sprecher dann an der stelle spreche für
mich ist nur eines bisher nicht ganz
klar gewesen ich dachte gesprochen wird
bei ihnen alleine auf der ebene des
fraktionsvorsitzenden mit der regierung
wenn ich jetzt von ihnen hören dass sie
sagen nein wir können auch hier im
parlament kleinen details reden dann bin
ich dazu als parlamentarier dem ich mir
sicher sind wir alle auch dazu gerne
bereit
ich hatte es bisher anders verstanden
das mag ja ein irrtum meinerseits sein
das sage ich ganz deutlich und wenn ich
den fraktionsspitzen sehe dann höre ich
jetzt das wäre ja auch an anderen
stellen gerne da auch verhandeln können
dann kommt aber etwas zweites dazu und
das will ich dann noch deutlich sagen
wenn wir parlamentarier versuchen
mehrheiten zu finden und ich verhandle
jetzt mit ihnen oder mit meinem konto
auf haushalts ebene verhandelt ich dann
mit der gesamten fraktion da hätte ich
gerne eine antwort oder verhandeln ich
nur mit dem teil der den teil ersetzt
wie wir es vom fraktionsvorsitz gehört
haben der reicht um die mehrheiten zu
erreichen wenn dann möchte ich mit der
gesamten cdu csu fraktion ein ergebnis
haben ein kompromiss der im endeffekt
heißt ein gegenseitiges nachgeben
entsprechend von kräften
kräfteverhältnissen und vernunft danke
super die zwei
kurzinterventionen
johann wadephul und fertig und gespräche
und schwieriger machen ich empfehle
ihnen herr kollege fricke mit dem
finanzminister
entsprechende gespräche zu führen es
geht ja nicht um weniger als darum ein
dass die verfassung zu ändern und hier
werden jetzt gespräche geführt die sind
ja auch richtig wir sind auch vereinbart
zwischen dem finanzminister und seinem
staatssekretär und zwei vertretern aus
unserer fraktion aber es geht darum eine
verfassungsänderung zu machen die weite
teile der bundeswehr und der
verteidigungspolitik umfasst und
deswegen fände ich ist eine gute kultur
dass wir breit angelegte gespräche
führen die alle fachbereiche mit
einbezogen werden die davon betroffen
sind das sind rechtspolitiker sind
verteidigungspolitiker und das ist
bisher nicht geschehen da sind da sage
ich nur da sind acht wochen jetzt
verstrich nur das ist ruhezeit wenn wir
vor der sommerpause die sache
verabschieden wollen dass das in einer
breite und in einer tiefe geschickt so
dass die fraktion in einer gesamtheit
sich eine meinung bilden kann und einer
möglichen verfassungsänderung zustimmen
kann das ist bisher nicht geschehen da
sollten sie sich bei 1 lindner noch mal
informieren und frau kollegin hasselmann
ich will dass wir noch mal in aller ruhe
so sagen bei gegenseitiger wertschätzung
die wirklich auch weiterhin besteht es
ist nicht der normalfall dass für die
finanzierung
eines wesentlichen teils des staates
nämlich ihre seiner streitkräfte die
verfassung geändert wird und ein
sondervermögen ehrlich gesagt ja sonder
schulden aufgenommen werden das ist
nicht der normalfall dass wollen sie
doch wohl nicht bestreiten oder wollen
sie uns jetzt bei jeder gelegenheit hier
auffordern die verfassung zu ändern
damit sie die notwendigen mittel haben
um dann ihre politik einfach gesetzlich
mit mit ihrer ampel mehrheit umzusetzen
das wollen sie doch nicht ernsthaft hier
behaupten und deswegen wiederhole ich
einfach in der sache die punkte über die
uneinigkeit besteht die
verfassungsänderung die sie uns vom text
her jetzt vorschlagen entspricht nicht
dem vorschlag den der herr bundeskanzler
gemacht hat dass es für die bundeswehr
ist das ist mal der erste punkt der
zweite punkt ist der bundeskanzler hat
vollkommen zu recht gesagt dass zwei
prozent ab jetzt und dauerhaft
eingehalten sind das sehen wir weder im
jetzigen haushalt noch in der
mittelfristigen finanzplanung der
bundesregierung sondern da sehen wir ein
einfrieren des einzel planes 14 der für
die bundeswehr vorgesehen ist auf gut 50
milliarden euro das ist lichtjahre von
zwei prozent entfernt und deswegen sage
ich schon die beiden punkte sind schon
nicht erfüllt und deswegen stimmt das
was mathias middelberg gesagt hat die
cdu csu fraktion ist sofort in der lage
die vorschläge des bundeskanzlers aus
seiner rede vom 27 februar eins zu eins
umzusetzen sie nicht und das ist der
unterschied
soweit die erwiderung auf zwei
kurzinterventionen und damit kommen wir
zum nächsten redner in dieser debatte
wolfgang hellmich ist das für die spd
fraktion ist der verteidigungspolitische
sprecher der sozialdemokraten wie hier
im deutschen bundestag
auch präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
kollegen die sachen liegen auf den
tischen sind ausgetauscht was macht man
in einer solchen situation sprechen
miteinander und ich glaube die debatte
darum wie man miteinander spricht und
wärmen man das spricht können wir an
dieser stelle gar nicht fortsetzen
sondern es wird die frage der handel nun
seien die
anzusprechen
ich habe am letzten wochenende etwas
länger mit meiner 96 jährigen mutter
gesprochen
das war mal dringend nötig ja aber sie
sagte mir sie hat angst
und ich glaube das was sie mir an angst
ausgewirkt hat mit einer ganz anderen
historische erfahrung als viele in
dieser gesellschaft war nicht nur sehr
ernst gemeint sie war tief getroffen und
sie haben gesagt ihr die in der politik
seit ist es eure auftrag ist eure
verantwortung für mich hier zu sorgen
damit ich weiter in sicherheit leben
kann und das ist die messlatte für das
was wir tun die mistel hatte die
erwartung von vielen menschen in dieser
gesellschaft in ganz europa und darüber
hinaus der der entgegenzukommen die auch
zu bedienen und zu sagen wir sind in der
tat mit voller verantwortung dafür diese
sicherheit auch zu garantieren sie hat
mir auch gesagt ich vertraue den
bundeskanzler
weil er mit ruhe und bedacht an diese
fragen angeht und kann dort schlagen an
keine lauten töne anspricht sondern klar
und verlässlich mit der situation die so
ernst ist wie sie nie war soweit sie das
erlebt hat die wahl auch damit umgeht
und 1000 probleme zu lösen und das mit
denjenigen
die an dieser in dieser situation an
unserer seite stehen
auch das war eine erfahrung die sie mir
mitgegeben hat nämlich mit denjenigen
die schon immer einmal für unsere
sicherheit besorgte auch in diesem
bündnis klar dafür zu sorgen dass es
frieden in diesem europa in dieser welt
gibt das ist die herausforderung
das ist das ziel das man sich setzen und
zu diesem ziel dieses ziel zu erreichen
gehören und dazu bin ich fest überzeugt
in einer werft demokratie in einem
werften land in einem werften europa in
werften bündnis werte streitkräfte und
erst dann bin ich er habe ich neue
erwartungen daran dass wir mit diesem
100 milliarden programm genau dieses
ziel wehrhafte streitkräfte zu haben
auch erreichen kann
wir kommen ja nun mal als
verteidigungspolitiker immer wieder mehr
aus dem maschinenraum
aus dem maschinenraum des konkreten tun
uns dann konkret machen sondern wissen
wo die defizite sind sehr konkret
ein zum beispiel hier auch genannt
wenn man hier nicht
führungsfähigkeiten hat und letztendlich
digitalisiert ins feld ziehen soll dann
braucht es die nötige ausstattung dazu
gehören aber nicht nur funkgeräte hat so
dazu werden in der nächsten zeit auch
die satelliten gehören die sicherstellen
dass die sicher kommunizieren können da
bin ich bei cyber sicherheit und die ist
nicht nur fragen der gesamten
gesellschaft sondern auch die frage
funktionsträger streitkräfte und ich
könnte viele dieser punkte fortsetzen
viele sind auch dabei genannt was
letztendlich angepackt werden mussten
das ziel einen handlungsfähigen
bundeswehr in ein bündnis zu erreichen
einsatzfähig zu sein und dieses bündnis
verpflichten nicht nur nachzukommen in
gegenseitiger verantwortung sondern noch
klar und deutlich zu machen wir stehen
dafür mit einer alterung und nicht nur
mit ankündigung sondern mit einer
haltung das tun zu wollen und umzusetzen
zu wollen was in dieser zeit notwendig
ist und deshalb meine herzliche bitte an
der story and ihren daran so ganz
persönlich dass ich irgendwann mal eine
mutter wieder besuchen kann dir sagen
kann wir haben dafür gesorgt dass du
zukünftig sicher reden kannst vielen
dank
und wolfgang hellmich war das will die
spd fraktion und wir kommen langsam zum
ende in dieser debatte zwei redner
stehen noch auf der rednerliste als
nächstes spricht johannes huber erst
mittlerweile fraktionslos
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
mitbürger putin hat in seiner
vertragsentwürfen über
sicherheitsgarantien im dezember 20 21
ultimativ ein ende der nato truppen in
14 staaten gefordert in osteuropa das
gilt bis heute und bedroht wie die
mittelstrecken raketen in kaliningrad
unmittelbar das bündnisgebiet das
russischer staatsmedien erc hat am
zweiten märz getwittert dass direkte
deutsche waffenlieferungen den
waffenstillstand von 1945 brechen das
klingt wie die aktuellste aussage von la
france der diese als einen de facto
kriegseinsatz des westens wertet also
offensichtlich russland auch bei
deutschland im krieg sieht russische
truppen sind bereits an der polnischen
grenze stationiert die nicht nur eine
cola über litauen einnehmen können
sondern auch das herz land europas also
polen bedroht und in der folge die
deutsche ostgrenze dass ein solches
szenario real werden kann zeigte der
hybride angriff von lukaschenko auf die
europäische union mit hilfe der
migrations waffe der nur mühsam dann der
polnischen grenze abgewehrt wurde die
teilweise selbst nur schulden der
bedrohungslage macht eine
schnellstmögliche materielle ausrüstung
der bundeswehr also unabdingbar auch die
wehrpflicht musste personell und
moralischen verteidigungsfähigkeit
wieder auf die tagesordnung den bedarf
für die bundeswehrzeit im übrigen die
kriegsführung in der ukraine es müssen
nicht nur die weiter entwickelten
eurofighter und transporthubschrauber
geschafft sondern für die lufthoheit vor
allem der blinde fleck der mobilen
flugabwehr im nahbereich des heeres mit
strenger bewachten ozelot systemen
enthoben werden auch bewaffnete drohnen
sind in der modernen kriegsführung
alternativlos für die hintendran tating
bei der landesverteidigung gegen eine
material überlegenen gegner braucht es
nicht nur miteinander eingespielt und
trainiert der soldaten
christen sondern in der ukraine auch
eine widerstandsfähige zivilbevölkerung
eine innenministerin die die eigene
bevölkerung aber es systematisch
entwaffnen will ist angesichts der
realen äußeren bedrohung ein
sicherheitsrisiko für unser land und ich
möchte schließen mit der
verteidigungsministerin die ebenfalls
unser aller sicherheit gefährdet wenn er
stolz noch da wäre dann könnte ich ihm
sagen und würde ich ihm sagen dass die
verteidigung die ja bereits jetzt quasi
vom kanzleramt ausübt dass er sich
selbst damit entlasten könnte aber auch
vor einem konstruktiven
misstrauensvotums sich schützen könnte
wenn es sich jemand als
verteidigungsminister an die seite
stellt die ahnung hat und strategische
und militärische kompetenz mitbringt
vielen dank
soweit johannes huber ehemals fdp
fraktionsmitglied mittlerweile
fraktionslos damit kommen wir zum
letzten redner und das ist andreas
schwarz ersetzt für die sozialdemokraten
im haushaltsausschuss
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen kollegen meine damen und
herren ab 24 zweiten hat sich die welt
durch putins angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine verändert oder scholz hat es
richtig mit dem wort zeitenwende
umschrieben an diesem 27
was hier im parlament nur ein wort in
den letzten wochen wurde dieses wort
aber mit handeln und mit leben erfüllt
von 100 milliarden sondervermögen bis zu
waffenlieferungen
wir erleben eine historische
verantwortung gerade die letzten wochen
war auch gezeigt dass diese zeitenwende
unterschiedlich gestaltet werden kann ja
jeder muss das so sein weg finden das
merken wir heute in dieser debatte mit
dieser zeitenwende umzugehen die
regierung muss sich positionieren was
wir klar getan haben die opposition muss
ihren platz finden wo sie gerade dabei
ist und das wichtigste ist wir müssen
die menschen in dem land in diese neue
zeit mitnehmen es gibt da viele sorgen
ja ängste bei den menschen und zu recht
darf ich anmerken es geht um krieg und
frieden die menschen erwarten jetzt von
uns zusammenhalt geschlossenheit und vor
allen dingen ein besonderes vorgehen die
frage ist wie gestalten mit dieser
zeitenwende welche zeit nehmen wir uns
für welche maßnahmen die zeitenwende
aber auch gezeigt meine damen und herren
dieses land hat viele militärexperten es
dürfte aber auch klar sein es gibt
beteiligte die haben keine zeit in
dieser zeitenwende nämlich unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten die brauchen
schnelle entscheidungen und darum geht
es bei dieser grundgesetzänderung
dafür braucht man mutige zügige und
besondere beschlüsse und keine
streitereien die frage der sicherheit
unseres landes darf nicht auf dem altar
des parteienstreits oder wahlkampfes
geopfert werden jetzt ist auch die zeit
einen schlussstrich zu ziehen uns hilft
kein blick zurück
sondern das hilft nur der blick nach
vorne natürlich könnte ich jetzt
philosophieren wer ist schuld an dem
zustand der bundeswehr hilft es aber
jetzt sicher nicht dieser krieg meine
damen und herren hat elementare folgen
für die sicherheit in europa und
natürlich müssen und haben wir auch
darauf reagiert mit dem sondervermögen
von 100 milliarden sind wir nun endlich
in der lage die anforderungen zu
erfüllen die die nato an und stellt
klares ziel ist eine leistungsfähige
truppe die die sicherheit unseres landes
gewährleistet und die menschen in
unserem land auch in europa schützt sehr
geehrte damen und herren wir müssen
jetzt dafür sorge tragen dass die
anschaffung schnell und unbürokratisch
realisiert werden und das wird schon
eine große aufgabe werden aber es sind
auch hier schon erste entscheidungen
getroffen worden 2,5 milliarden euro
schutzausstattung für unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten die entscheidung bei der
tornado und auch folge um nur zwei zu
nennen dazu gehört aber
selbstverständlich auch eine dringende
veränderung im system
wir alle wissen dass die reformen im
beschaffungswesen überfällig sind und
ich danke frau ministerin dass sie
schnell tätig geworden ist die
zauberworte die hier viel helfen heißen
anhebungen der nieder schwellenwert
vergabe von 1000 oder 5000 euro schnelle
direktvergaben unter nutzung des
eu-rechts kauf markt verfügbarer
produkte verehrte kolleginnen kollegen
wir schaffen aber auch zusätzliche
sicherheit da das sondervermögen den
kernhaushalten nicht angreift es wird
kein ausspielen das eine gegen das
andere geben das bedeutet im gegenzug
natürlich auch weiter ausreichende
mittel für die bereiche der inneren und
vor allen dingen auch der sozialen
sicherheit zu haben und das ist ja das
was unser land auch so stark macht und
auch stark immer durch krisen gebracht
hat mit einem neuen absatz in artikel
87a thron gesetz kann der bund jetzt mit
eigenem kreditermächtigungen ein
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
einrichten durch diese verhandlung wird
sichergestellt dass diese mittel nicht
für andere zwecke eingesetzt werden
können alle hier im haus sollten sich
dieser verantwortung bewusst seien
und für die grundgesetzänderung stimmen
unsere bevölkerung unser land und vor
allen dingen unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten erwarten dass von uns und auch
hier zurecht dankeschön
soweit also diese erste beratung zum
bundeswehr sondervermögen morgen geht es
hier im bundestag mit unserer
übertragung weiter unter anderem wird es
dort um eine unterstützung für die
ukraine gehen ab 8.45 sind wir dann
wieder für sie aus dem deutschen
bundestag bereit jetzt gebe ich aber ab
zu den kollegen von der tmx
der tag
dann beginne ich mit einem dankeschön an
katharina kühn meine kollegin in berlin
willkommen zur heute etwas späteren
nachmittags ausgabe von phoenix der tag
die bundesregierung die sieht angesichts
der folgen des ukraine kriegs deutliche
risiken für die konjunktur in
deutschland sie rechnet in diesem jahr
mit einem schwächeren
wirtschaftswachstum der heute
vorgelegten frühjahrsprojektion wird nur
noch ein wachstum des
bruttoinlandsprodukts von 2